two oh hello there welcome everybody to
Friday's after dark history coming at
you live
from the very hot the very dry Los
Angeles you know what it is
hi hi girls I don't know if it's like
this or like that no it's like this
right it's all over the above like
you're grabbing it's like you're
grabbing right yeah it's like I love you
so so much it's a grabbing motion
uh thank you guys for being here we have
a great show planned for a change we
have um Gila here who looks phenomenal I
love your outfit thank you you look
great you look radiant which I think
probably means you're pregnant
that makes sense but I don't know I
don't know yet I don't know what makes
sense about it because I don't feel
radiant oh you don't but you do look but
you're saying I look ready
stand up show it off
love the outfit
oh that's radiant whoa yeah yeah and
then just just as proof that I'm such a
great husband show the bag
foreign
thank you I bought this bag for ELO's
birthday like I don't know it was last
year the year before I don't think I
don't even think you've worn it before
you know what I mean
I hit her with that oh it's Gucci
actually it looks like a Chanel bag but
it's not
very cool
it's the Goot I haven't seen it a lot
which is very cool that's you know I
have connections that's the only reason
they forget it
um today we don't have a sponsor but I
do want to give a big shout out to my
lovely wife's um
project known as Teddy fresh who just
put out a new uh part two collection
yesterday yes this lots of um fan
favorites restocks happened here this is
the one that Abu was wearing this is the
ab famous super hype it's super hype
yeah
um it is summer the hottest summer ever
so
depends where you live
[Applause]
um tie-dye long sleeve there's a lot of
warm stuff and it's like the hottest
it's ever been literally this is like
the hottest month I know right what's
the month we're in the end of July some
people start buying like towards fall at
this point I never understood that I'll
be honest a lot of people already bought
their summer stuff
they always go oh here's our fall
collection you're like fall it's like
like it's 100 degrees you want
to release something and have a few
months of selling it not real estate I'd
have like two weeks of selling yeah so I
buy something when I want to wear it now
not when I want to wear it in a month
that's crazy to me
am I the only one um girlies do you have
an opinion a month we like to plan ahead
is that right you'll buy first you'll
buy for fall well I get I think maybe I
I get a little excited and I'm like time
to shop for summer and then it's time to
shop for fall because I already I
already did Summer got it your guys is
um everything year round and then I just
save it yeah
me too so you guys are shopping Cycles I
let stuff marinate in my closet for a
while like that bag I bought you yeah
thanks a month no seriously I kind of
like doing that because it has to adapt
to us yeah it has to marinate okay
that's what I do with video games so I
understand oh there you go my Steam
my thousands of Steam games I've never
played right here okay you know it's a
fair comparison uh the Corduroy
Patchwork shirt is incredible incredibly
this is kind of Summer Vibes I guess
yeah if you're going to the beach I
guess in the evening hide your arms and
it's a little cold
don't be so immodest
um this is pretty cool the sun help
roulette yeah bro yeah bralette is this
our first ever bralette
um we had like a couple we're still
pretty new and just gotta go
we're entering the bralette category out
here got some Acid Trip t-shirts those
are free stocks of stuff that people had
already had already sold out and we were
just brought back those restocks by the
way this necklace Hassan was wearing
yesterday it looked really good
and he was wearing it from the first
time I love that he loved study first so
much every time I hear him talk about it
on the show I'm like he does this is so
cool fancy I think he wears those every
day I don't think he wears any other
pants and straight up I seriously made a
restocking block just for him there you
go there you go
yeah it's awesome love that first
love that for him uh we got matching
earrings send help shirt this one oh
it's sold out again oh wow that happened
fast iconic
Flames cardigan the rug is gone again
people love the rug huh the rug yeah
rugs are cool
and uh I've been getting so many
um happy feedback from people I know
personally about the swimsuit is that
one still available no it's sold out oh
okay the dolphin Sunset swimsuit one but
that was really cool to see and um I'm
excited to make more right I wasn't sure
how that would do frankly if people were
interested in buying yeah but but they
are it was fun thank you flipper I just
saw my friend tati and she was wearing
it as a top with jeans so cool oh
interesting
that's very interesting flipper approved
actually
what's that boy
you say there's a there's a boat at sea
and they likely plays for it they've
been stuck at sea for two days
take me to them
all you guys I guarantee are way too
young I only I've seen flipper Nick at
night Nick at night rerun when I was
young it was on TV that and that and
Lassie it's pretty much the same show
Lassie
yeah it's it's Lassie the dolphin I
never liked Mr Ed I didn't get it I
didn't like that he spoke he just stood
there he let every time I watched Mr Ed
he's just standing in a stable I don't
trust the horses
turn them in the glue let's
Michelle this elasticity we're
talking about like old old old dude
I like Old Yeller
when we were kids it was on Nick at
night which was the for the people but
flipper was I guess he could talk to the
dolphin
uh it was I remember the name flipper I
think the dolphin and flipper like
killed itself or something oh no say
anything so it was so sad from being
captive it like drowned itself God no I
could have that wrong
or maybe he lived a happily life forever
and ever yeah I'm sure the show business
dolphin was really happy you say you're
suicidal boy you say let me go or or
else I'm I'm gonna drown myself so he's
like a child star dolphin
[Music]
I'm trying to find a credible Source but
the first three articles said that
flipper did drown
dude isn't that nuts I know yeah
no seriously no it's possible with
stories like that and that's so sad well
you know what's crazy think about this
whenever a sea mammal dies yeah they
drown
you know dolphins whales wait a second
dumbass how'd they drown they just they
can't swim and they just drown
I feel like maybe we're blurring the
lines how they need their lungs fill up
with they need to go around every 30
minutes you know they surface for air
but they're really I don't like this
conversation
it occurred to me one day I was like
whoa that's pretty that's scary they
just drown that is interesting
but what you're saying is that he
committed suicide no they can dolphins
and orca they're so smart they they can
see where they won't come up for air
orcas have done that too where they just
yeah dolphins or mammals yeah they need
so true they come up they go down
damn it yeah orca's just drowned
dude
I was so excited for today's show thank
you for the death bell by the way that
that really tied the teeth together what
the
um there's a comment here saying how
come AB didn't save him
yeah what the dude that's on you
baby
God's on you bro I don't think I was
born yet otherwise oh yeah I like this
sounds like an excuse to me like uh hey
Gabe one sec here and so the flame
hoodie this piece is really cool this is
the one that fousey was wearing that he
was really looking good in new Teddy
fresh Ambassador the team pads the
swimsuit this shirt I love this shirt
too iconic
this is let me tell you about this one
it's a custom stripe that I personally
designed I picked every color
and we made the fabric because sometimes
you pick like available stripes
there it is so consider supporting us at
teddyfish.com
and die of heat stroke
Gabe can I tell you something gave
shocking
what is it to this is this hottest year
in human history recorded human history
do you know what my thought was the last
six hottest years
when was the last six hot years in
recorded human history
the last six years the last six years
no no that's the answer that's the
answer the last time the last six years
yeah isn't that that's that's that's
cool we'll be fine
the water's 100 degrees off Florida
there's nothing wrong
how you doing today Gabe I'm good that's
such like a Facebook question you know
no yeah
when was the last six years
talking over each other okay I'm sorry
go ahead what were you saying no I just
tie-dye a shirt I just made this one you
did oh that looks really good
is that a long sleeve
it looks like a long sleeve yeah that's
awesome man it looks like you bought it
at us yeah are you sure you didn't just
buy it at the store okay why would you
lie about tie-dye
I'm not saying he's okay hold on hold on
hold on can I see the label can I see
the label
hmm
yeah show us the label Gabe let me see
let me see
the label is clean it's a blanket tell
us about the process of tie-dying I
think the label I think you have to you
have to get some tie and then put it in
water and then like put it on the shirt
and then like let it dry I just want to
say I think the label would have caught
color when you tie-dye that why is the
label white Gabe unless it's made of
synthetic which could be
um that's that I think it's
so when did you when did you tie-dye the
shirt Gabe yeah
I did it um
a few days ago okay a few days ago yeah
flip it around let me see the front
settle in let me see the front
[Music]
we're gonna get to the bottom of this
tie-dye thing oh
oh okay why would you lie about
tie-dying
that's a Maui shirt Gabe
we think you're cool regardless you
don't you know what I mean like we don't
care if you tie-dyed her shirt or not we
love you all the same yeah but I'm
trying to experiment like this shirt
here yeah this is kind of bleach I'm
trying to find some way to bleach this
one let me see oh do it well that one
just looks like someone stained it with
bleach yeah I'm an experiment trying to
yeah bleach this one let me see you can
um you know it's fine you can draw with
the Bleach yeah
okay look at this Gabe is in the uh
laboratory by the way check this out
Gabe
experiment check this out everything's
fine
this is global climate since 1980 I mean
you can see it goes back to 1880 but you
can see that everything's been really
fine uh in the past six years uh I mean
the past 20 years has really been
like totally fine nothing to worry about
here nothing to see here folks
I up one of those I don't know if
it's global warming or one of those 100
year you know things where it just gets
warm and then it gets cold in a few
years and it gets warm again it's an up
and down thing that's what I think okay
so global warming is overblown it's the
natural cycles of the earth warming and
cooling probably
probably
[Music]
there's like that slide whistle yeah
it's just
[Music]
but yeah I mean it looks like success
you know this is how you want your
investment to look the numbers go up
baby to the Moon yeah that's a big
investment
I would agree with you Gabe except like
the acceleration of heat I mean I agree
that Earth does go through natural
Heating and warming Cycles
based on like how close we are to the
Sun and stuff like that yeah but that
the acceleration of heating is really
unnatural if you look at these heating
warming Cycles they take place over like
tens of thousands of years this is 20
years you know what I mean and the
temperature's gone up what
you know exponentially so that implies
that it's probably
most almost certainly from Human uh
human activity here on Earth
a lot of activity raises the temperature
so like you go into a room you put more
people in the room yeah temperature of
the room goes up gives up the human heat
right yeah where batteries it's a decent
metaphor you know what's uh did you know
that cow farts gave uh comprise uh
a decent amount of carbon emissions
cow fart yeah
cow farts actually are heating the earth
I swear
it's just like natural exhaust that's
right they have an exhaust pipe in their
well that's why a lot of people say beef
is so bad because they they eat tons of
food they take tons of land and they
fart out tons of gas I do have a small
correction
um the vast majority of the methane
produced by cows is from their burps not
oh they're burping herbs yes
according to nasana how dirty
okay that is interesting to know yeah
and there what is it
that's like a burp you burp out the you
know right yeah what do you think out of
your mouth and then you apply it and it
blows fire yeah like a dragon yeah hey
Gabe how you doing uh how are you
keeping cool this weekend
yeah
um usually I go to the beach or I just
you know stay inside
Beach would be nice you got any plans
this weekend
we're trying to watch a fight um Errol
Spence versus Terrell Crawford it's
gonna be good the fights nice yeah three
fights baby
listen to this excuse me
14.5 of global greenhouse gas emissions
is from livestock
supposed to be natural
oh it's natural baby
all right
well listen it is Friday
baby
hey in the cow and burp it
out
far out of my mouth and put it in the
air baby yeah walk up the heat
you know what's a good thing to do Gabe
if you're trying to fight global climate
change when you what is it when you fart
you gotta suck in the air real fast to
prevent it from reaching the air
and then it prevents global climate
change yeah I'm a good husband I do that
when ELO farts too right yeah he really
cares
yeah
that's what you do
if you really care yeah reuse recycle
and reduce and restart
it turns out the lungs is the best
filtering system for CO2 so if you're on
to something breathe deep my friends
clean clean carbon dioxide
CO2 how about see these nuts
[Music]
and breathing in my mouth
that was so loud so unnecessary it's not
unnecessary
I can I say maybe it was too loud okay
and that I harmed your ears in some way
that I would apologize for but they say
it's unnecessary okay okay okay but it's
a little aggressive yeah it's Friday
baby all right listen Gabe um always a
treasure always a treat to see that
beautiful face
you know bring so much Joy to the World
how's the cameos going you're still
crushing it I'm still doing it no slurs
right
no slurs since last time no no I'm not
gonna do that get in trouble good very
good
right I'm gonna we're gonna have to do a
presentation on climate change for you
Gabe I'm a little bit I'm a little bit
concerned about you saying that it's um
just a climate cycle I know a lot of
people do say that though that's one of
the things one of the main talking
points of people who try to deny and the
seriousness of maybe we could do a
little like classroom setting we got a
symposium yeah
have you ever seen An Inconvenient Truth
I have no clue man yeah Al Gore
apparently maybe that all right listen
[Music]
somebody said my boyfriend has a literal
fart fetish
oh
right on
I got you damn you know what I did I had
to transform I had to like take myself
somewhere else mentally I hate I almost
hate to admit this but I was I had
thought about the saddest thing I could
to keep me online
no I was thinking about Shredder
I'm just saying I I know it's I'm just
this I had no friends today I had to
transform I had to transport myself
there
and uh that's how we win here we go
congrats man
all right Gabe take care okay
love you buddy have a great weekend okay
climate change is real all right buddy
okay all right thanks man for that and
it's man-made it's being influenced by
people all right especially their farts
especially the parts suck them up
all right so what we're learning today
bye Gabe thank you bye
we've learned that if you have a fart
fetish you're actually a sustainable
person green it's a green fetish that's
a green fetish people should put it in
their dating profiles
what about you
yeah so that's Gabe uh White Cloud Gabe
or the artist formerly known as white
cloud gate he's now known as Uncle Gabe
yeah
we don't talk about white climbing you
should button that
oh I should button the white cloth yeah
no it's probably too late all right
um
let's see so today we're doing a little
mini game throughout
because love is Mr law
yeah he is he's doing a game you know we
did guess who's hired who's drunk and so
love today is Raise Your Glass there
love I should follow right now we don't
know is there alcohol or is there just
uh gamer sup in it I like gamer stuff I
know you do use the gamer stuff
where's I don't have gamer sub today
what
um
what alcohol would that be is that like
white lion or champagne
what are we guessing I don't know if
that's too much information take a look
or it could be one of those like
lemonade
alcoholic kind of Beverage in a can
I mean we have a lot of alcohol here it
could just be vodka with any damage oh
okay okay
um but we're gonna we're gonna
interrogate him in about an hour
my sense is that this dude is drunk as
all right don't drink you never
drink no I but then you're strong so
you're saying that's why I can easily
tell
well I don't I don't like drinking you
know yeah in general okay
so you're saying you wouldn't be
drinking today because you don't like
drinking right no but what you know what
he's saying is the reason that I can
tell so obviously is because he doesn't
drink a lot so he shows it
right
that's what yeah that's what I mean yeah
okay so you're drunk I'm not drunk
well this is gonna be fun I mean I would
say no to drink it I remember uh I
remember drunk love in Vegas
[Music]
I've never been like like more scared in
my life because you guys all was like
what the is going on I just wanted
you to look in the mirror and make sure
you don't I don't want you to die on
artwork
but I went into the bathroom I shake my
my cheeks and I was like your cheeks
your cheeks were red I slightly red
but he got really worried about he took
two seconds he went in the mirror got
really close goes the I'm fine it
walked out yeah Avery was with me I
think what happened just I don't know if
I ever said this detail right but I
think a b started that he he tapped me
on the shoulder I was like yo check out
love I'm worried about him I think we
were all worrying everybody that was it
that was an A B special I believe but I
agreed with you I mean I don't I don't
remember I don't know what you're saying
is AB was trying to save somebody okay
oh yeah maybe yeah I just remember Eli
saying that maybe I should follow him to
make sure he's okay on the way to the
bathroom yes I do I remember being very
worried because we were kind of like the
parents you know that's what I'm saying
I don't want anything happening on an
hour why I don't know I will say I'm not
very impacted by alcohol like I can take
alcohol pretty easily well you are
Swedish I am Swedish and there is a gene
apparently I've been told that Swedish
people don't drunk as easily that's
America interesting yeah
sweet we're gonna have to fat chick
chicken I've heard of similar things uh
do sweet that they don't get drunk as
easily yeah like I know on average it
takes more alcohol really I know some
people are genetically uh predisposed to
being alcoholics which is crazy really
yeah like Native Americans there was um
well there's a lot of people if
alcoholism runs in your family okay
people are saying it's like a disease
but isn't it that Native Americans had
like this propensity genetically I hope
that's not
a totally untrue thing that most people
will be mad at you for saying well let's
look it up I know there was a big
problem with alcoholism in the Native
American Community like it was ravaging
certain communities yeah yeah no that's
definitely interesting and then there's
people who cannot handle alcohol right
like
losers no dumbass idiot dumbass idiots
Loser yeah I'm just saying that you know
there's body weight metabolism genetic
factors but there's no specific uh trait
linked to a certain group of people or
nationality there's no single standard
for how individuals from a specific
nationality or ethnic group will react
to alcohol surely that's not true okay
but yeah it's a drug I mean you're
taking a drug it's not like oh I don't I
need less of this drug because I'm
Swedish there could be other factors
like you like the like swedes like diet
or something maybe that contributes to
it that I'm talking about but okay that
makes sense yeah the diet I could see
yeah it's all the fika the Tsum is true
I don't know if this is another like not
true thing but I've always been told
that like Russians drink a lot of vodka
because it's cold there I think it's
just because they're degenerates how
dare you
I'm kidding yeah I think people in
colder climates do drink more I think
yeah
so does that make them more capable
capable to handle alcohol
uh
no no uh here okay here okay according
to National Institute on alcohol abuse
and alcoholism the findings suggests
that it is unlikely that Native
Americans carry genetic variant that
disposes them dis predisposes them to
alcoholism okay I was wrong more Native
American um
propaganda propaganda given to me by
Ronald Reagan or somebody
Ronald Reagan probably said that
although it could be fair to me it says
unlikely
I mean I have heard that a lot too but I
have never actually looked into it
that's why when you said it was like I
don't know I feel like nowadays whenever
you like have a memory of a statement
like that it's almost most likely like
oh that's actually some fake propaganda
that's right that's just pretty much
trying to push some other narrative like
in elementary school when they tell you
that Thomas Jefferson married one of his
slaves okay now here's now recording the
uh sorry what in History Class growing
up they tell you that Thomas Jefferson
married one of his slaves I heard he r
word it is I heard that as well as I
grew up I don't think she can consent to
marriage when she's a slave absolutely
you will marry me I mean that's not even
a joke I mean that's not funny no yeah
well as you as Pearl famously said uh
you know no no no that was on Fox News
recently they're doing this revisionism
they go well you know some skills that
slaves learned
during their time as slavery really
helped them when they were freed
and the one that I always hear them
bring up is like blacksmithing for some
reason they go yeah they learn to do
blacksmithing and then they were freed
they had just went and had an easy time
being a blacksmith yeah totally
like are you crazy that's the
lead
breaking news slave gets incredible
skills
oh here we go the Asian flush is a thing
that's what I was thinking about where
Asians turn red from drinking alcohol
right that is I personally know people
yeah that's the thing according to this
this is interesting too we're
demystifying all this Russia's cold
climate has historically made it
challenging to cultivate grapes for wine
making which led to the development of
grain-based spirits like vodka as a more
viable alternative every single one
of those kind of like things you've
heard most likely are wrong
it's true that some countries consume a
lot more alcohol than others but I think
that's just a cultural thing
sure
some consume a lot more like the English
luscious dude definitely Cabot
the stats are the most drunk at
um I I
believe we looked this up not that long
ago and uh oh we did it the highest uh
in the world I believe is South Korea
from what from the last time we had this
discussion do they drink Sake or there's
like rice beer they drink or is it
soccer well it's and it's largely a
cultural thing and they have this in
Japan as well in Japan also has is
pretty far up there but they have a
drinking work culture where it is
expected to go out with your co-workers
and drink all the time
and uh yeah what country consumes the
most elk let's see I wanna I wanna I
wanna uh scoreboard here uh South Korea
uh obvious drinking country there you go
um here
oh wait these are specifically Asian
countries hold on oh damn what are you
trying to prove
alcohol consumption by country real
quick uh Eli is correct about the uh
Asian uh I'm sorry how do you phrase it
uh asian
flush yes
um so yes some agents particular those
of East Asian descent may experience
thank you
[Music]
I hit it are you there no dad you hit it
okay that's why
there we go let's go let me try to
rephrase that I love it then button it's
not it's whatever it was one of the
first times I've actually done it you
didn't hit it no I did it you did hit it
it did that's probably for the best yeah
Asians have a genetic variant that makes
their earwax different
I swear to God they have dry earwax what
it's like a different consistency why
would you know that I heard it somewhere
it's interesting yeah yeah like uh on
the like dry earwax subreddit no is it I
heard it on the news or something what
earwax says about your ancestry that is
correct okay
get me that that uh truth tell uh the
James Charles truth seller guy going
true that's true correct
go ahead
there's a lot here uh the wet type of
ear is more common among people of
European and African descent while the
dry type is more prevalent among people
of East Asia right here yeah we got wet
here girl yeah no wet ears got a lot
waxy kind of thing going on here the
difference in earwax type is primarily
due to a single genetic variation in a
gene called abcc
[Laughter]
you know racism is so silly imagine
being like let me check your ear your
ear wax top there son we don't allow no
love can you not be so obviously drunk
please what's he doing he's just put it
he had his head back he's like falling
asleep he doesn't even know we're
talking about him yeah you can cut to
you he he doesn't even know we're
talking if I missed him
that's something you're it's all part of
the it's all part of the ACT it's I'm
acting you're a high level yeah
thank you guys yeah I don't lock dry
earwax folks round these parts let me
take a swab that ear see if it's wet or
not
um
I like to hang out with my fellows with
wet wax hmm we get around talk about
them dry wax fellas they ain't right in
the head boy oh boy I'll tell you what
man I knew Feller there with dry earwax
you just wouldn't ripe
name with Jeb live across from me
I know this one day as we were standing
together at the Sue we Fair Festival not
the zoo wee first of all we was at the
pig hollering contest
I just taken second place bit devastated
but you know I'll get them next year
so I looked over at my friend jab
noticed something weird about his ears
looked a little dry
now when I look into a friends or
somebody's ear there I know it's just a
little more it's a little shiny slick
you know
runny whacks like a good man has like
God intended for the ear to be waxy and
wet
and I saw jebs looking like a black hole
of dry dry dry flavorish devilish ear
wax like Satan's flame lit from his
eardrums and dried his ears out from the
inside
they probably listen to Metallica they
have dry ears
I could hear Metallica resonating from
his ears boy
well I went home that night I told mom
misses you know Jeb got them dry earwax
she didn't like that none because her
friend
she played with his missus they play Jim
rummy every Saturday night
and she didn't know she's in the
presence of a dry wax Feller
so one day I went over Jeb's house how
to talk with him Jeb come on out here I
want to talk to you
you know about this time of year it's
hurricane Seasons they come the blow
across the fields
I call them twisters
one year about few bat twister came
through tore the whole church up
every goddamn thing we found that cross
right upside down digging in the dirt we
said this some kind of sign
does God's work someone else's
came back that cross was digged down
deep in the dirt from the upside down
now that's Satan
[Music]
and I said and when I met when I stood
there faced Jim in the face I says to
him
I know who done that with the cross why
that happened now was that dry earwax
brought God's wrath upon us fine people
didn't deserve it
and I thought about the good folks that
perished in that twister and I thought
and I looked at Jeb's dry ears and I
went into a maddening rage
I knew it was dry I knew it was the dry
ears that it killed Pappy's or little
Lassie down at the church please clap
twister came rolling through she didn't
have no chance escaping that she's in a
wheelchair dang stupid 79 years old
I took Jab
I grabbed him by the husk I said damn
you try ear wax son of a gun
he said I told I tried to die I didn't
choose to have no dry ears
I said I don't care Jeb you you
up
I'm not proud to say what happened next
but uh
I gutted him like a fish
[Laughter]
took my long knife from my back pocket
shoved it in and
sliced it down
you know when you grab a fish they
wiggle real hard for life well Jeb
wiggled like them fish
took them out
his insides Spilled Out like a ear wax
you're supposed to look
but inside he was dry
ain't no blood it was bone dry inside
the man the work of the devil
[Music]
took him back to my house and
threw some holy water on him and buried
him with a cross in a Bible so hopefully
in the afterlife someone take better
care of him than in this life
not think about Jeb sometimes I mean
it's true he didn't be born choose to be
born with them dry earwax now but uh sir
some people they just
not for this world
that's right please clap
you know does the does the child
predator choose to be born a child
predator no but they not for this world
they just say it right
I want my fault Jeb born here with a
goddamn earwax his mom and daddy
probably had sex and that's what
happened incest done that that kind of
Injustice on this planet
probably made a pact with the devil or
some kind of unholiness
[Music]
seen jab walk around town like he all
that with that dry ear wax
you don't have to use swabs or nothing
I got sick of that smug dry ear boy I'll
tell you right now
see how dry it is in the ground
anyway no welcome back I could have kept
going
forward thank you
I only do that for the
um people won't accuse me of writing
ahead of time again
which would be weirder right there
man I could do a whole show like that I
could I could do it
would that be avant-garde I mean Subway
avant-garde Subway eating a Subway
sandwich on my card yeah kind of
we could plan it where like something
comes out on the green screen you guys
start slowly putting costume on me
you could slowly change me bring a set
out like Broadway then I'll break into
song I have ideas
we'll talk about it
got a friend will live here she said she
got some ideas
yeah thing about ideas
in the winter save it for the next one
dancing
wrap it up Hello Olivia nope oh my God
absolutely not have you watched have you
talked about some of the things we've
watched we haven't talked about anything
yet in this show we've literally done
nothing I know I know I know but not in
this show because like I was just
thinking about like veteran pump rules
yeah when we started watching dude okay
when we are addicted
uh oh um okay I saw that love what
you're drunk bro you'd have to drink
that I haven't drinking anything I have
a couple of drinks you have to get
trashed I have not drinking a single
drink the only thing I've been hitting
is gamer soap all right
okay
we'll see about that
it's Ewing this row I'm just seeing love
at the end shaking everything's shaking
on this table for the past like half
hour his lights his monitor
it does not every every episode tell me
when are we good to do because I'm ready
to do a field sobriety test on love sure
I'm ready
should he drink a little more Ian what
do you think before you move on I just
wanted to say we watched um Paradise
Lost over the break I know it's been so
long since the break but this is my
memory yeah really oh wow such an
amazing documentary yes if anybody
hasn't watched it oh my God about the
West Memphis Three is what they call
them right
that's what it was right I complainting
on the whole thing it's about
how like there there were three kids who
died seriously yes okay and then the
whole town decided that it was this kid
who listens to Metallica right right why
because he just listens to Metallica and
wears black yeah that's why it was like
making a murderer like but 30 years ago
it's one of the best documentaries I've
ever seen and it's like magic I mean the
way the story unfolds in three parts
it's like magic literally it was just
like counterculture Panic yeah yeah
crazy they straight up lock this kid up
and it was two others it was like the
one who was like is him okay it's on HBO
and it was just like into making a
murderer they coerced the confession
from one of his friends whose borderline
like the IQ yes and and also so so there
was three of them that they accused and
put in jail and all three were also kids
themselves
like when you're watching them they're
so young they were like what are we
talking about 16 yeah actually but
the the murder itself that took that was
the heart of that was so heinous man and
um
like uh one of the most heinous crimes I
ever heard of so I understand like the
more the Panic that gripped the town but
I I highly recommend watching that it's
phenomenal one of the best documentaries
ever you know who recommended that Alex
Pardee recommended that to me so that
was a that was a really good he
recommended you so many good ones
um the other one was America what
America's America American film American
Film so good oh and then the one about
LARPing was amazing America American
Film yes you just recently watched that
yes
so good
on paper you're like how is this gonna
be a good movie yeah the bruxim broke
wannabe filmmakers dude it's desire to
make the best film ever and they're just
total like broke rednecks
I don't know I'm not trying but I don't
know if they're rednecks necessarily but
like it's just it's such a like
timepiece I feel like seeing this
character is at that time and everybody
looks
good though but the main guy is so
entertaining and his best friend is
amazing and his best friend yeah it's a
feel-good film really kind of yeah it's
yeah it's not true no it's not right not
bad it's it's a Bittersweet movie I
would say like
it's interesting
you guys like True Crime you have to see
Natalia Grace
the
case of Natalia yeah we we just watched
why that too
I I watched it oh my god did you see the
Cliffhanger it ended on yeah I was
screaming yeah I can't believe they did
that so I can we discuss I feel like
people need to watch it because I don't
want to like well I don't remember the
Cliffhanger but I do remember thinking
and I don't know if I want to spoil it
or not I mean it is a documentary it
already happened right that one is on
Hulu
maybe I won't say it but um
yeah yeah maybe we can talk about it in
a week give everybody an opportunity
it's pretty good it's not as good as
these other ones I'd I'd prioritize
these other ones the other ones are more
like works of art it's just a different
category for me
yeah yeah I would say that I but it's
very good
the story is like mind-blowing oh I
remember how it ended yeah that was
insane yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah I know what you're talking about
yeah that was really good and I forgot
um oh you know what that's another one
Alex party recommended yeah you agree
like such a good list I just want to say
real quick I totally forgot even to tell
you Cameron but Alex party is the man I
was talking about uh I was telling him
how we want to go to Comic-Con he
offered to not only get minolino's
tickets but he was gonna buy your ticket
Cameron for like over 300 I forget what
it was yeah it is a birthday gift so
yeah he's he's genuine he's like the
greatest guys he's awesome he's Howie
Mandel level right
ascended also he's so professional
oh yeah just amazing he was really
professional to work with another one
that is like really zany and just
unexpectedly good that Alex again
recommended
um monster camp
that was the one about the larpers oh I
loved it have you seen that one Dan no
dude it's so then you're gonna love it
again uh monster Camp monster about a
group of larpers their real life action
they playing like playing out D and D in
real life like a specific game that they
all play that I've never heard of it's
it's fun it's phenomenal yeah
it's phenomenal
so uh what were we talking about yeah
nothing uh Vander plump enough with the
good stuff we've been watching talk
about some traps okay so Vander plump
rules
I was skeptical
because there was this huge drama of
Vanderpump Rules where there was some
cheating thing and everyone's saying
it's the best
yeah the best drama that ever happened
reality TV it's kind of all so we were
like do we skip to the do we skip to
that and I went online says where should
I start Vanderpump Rules it's got like
12 seasons 13. and these are just
they're just random bartenders I was
like I don't care they said start from
season one that's literally reality TV
gold I said okay season one the best the
best oh good season two the on even
better season three now it's even better
these people are the most dysfunctional
Psychopathic freaks
I've never seen and it's all of them all
of them are crazy it's just random
employees for Lisa Vanderpump's
restaurant yes and they're so like let
me give you an example
there's this dude Jax
he's been best friends
with this dude Tom
for a decade that's kind of like a major
um plot twist though if you're gonna
tell it if people haven't watched it I
think I know it's been out for like 10
years I think people need to understand
how crazy it is oh no yeah
okay well I'll just put it in in like
terms so it turns out
this dude's girlfriend she's so paranoid
that he's cheating on her to the point
where it drives them apart and then the
guy he finds out his best friend Jax
his girlfriend the one that was
so paranoid while he was sleeping in the
other room two years prior
and then when he confronted his best
friend he was like I don't care I don't
feel bad about it at all is it like
I was like what I said yeah I mean these
people these people saying they've been
best friends for 10 years
and he slept with his girlfriend while
the other guy was in the room and for no
reason and for no reason no reason he
doesn't even like her it doesn't even
like but no for no reason he says to his
friend I don't care I'm not sorry for no
reason
and then the next season he forgives him
and they hang out again together
but they still hate the girl but then
the girl who cheated on his best friend
and that Caesar we're watching on now
she's obsessed with trying to get him
back and she's trying to ruin his
current relationship she is so insane
it's fantastic have you seen this it
sounds incredible you have to watch
bander plump
because it's plump and juicy with teeth
like a lip plumper yeah wow Vander plump
so the friend was just like my bad
that was it no he didn't say that so he
kind of like after season one he kind of
like confronts everybody with all of his
bad stuff that he's done like he he
starts telling the truth he's actually
like one of the worst people on earth
like when the stuff pays down to the
friends so at that point he's kind of
like yeah that's just me I don't care I
don't have feelings well he goes no well
you cheated on your girlfriend so why do
you care that I your girlfriend
he's like you've cheated before like he
he I can't believe what I'm seeing Mike
Jones on the ground every episode is
truly stunning nice and they're all
wannabe actors so it's like and I can't
wait to see like what happens until
season 10 because that's the famous
Scandal that I don't even know what it
is and right now Tom is the victim I see
him as the victim of his insane ex but
Tom's the one sort of victim because
like you can tell that he did cheat on
his girlfriend but still
is kind of like the victim right now so
sort of in the new season 10 he becomes
the ultimate villain and that character
Arc is very exciting to me so Dan you
should watch that
is Ali watching it already specifically
I think she does watch that one she's
the best of course she does yeah so
that's what I'm saying I was resistant
because I was like this is so stupid why
would I watch this but it is actually
the best he's the because yeah it's a
spin-off of the
because Lisa was one of the house right
and then they started this show so it
was sort of a spin-off yeah but it's not
even about her it's just about her
bartender well it's a little right yeah
because it's her restaurant and she
always like kind of like chimes in
she'll pop in sometimes yeah she's a
minor character yeah
but not
she's Flander plum
all right are we gonna talk about
anything this show what else um you want
to talk about IVF stuff
you know how I know you're pregnant
because it's a boy
and Klein boys we make it baby they
happen
there was a comment earlier ago but you
were going on and on about out of stuff
but I wanted to read it it was super
chat about IVF something somebody else
that's going through it
I don't know if you guys have a way to
go back because I can't uh Napoleon said
Ethan natives don't necessarily have a
specific Gene that predisposes them but
they didn't ever have alcohol in their
history until later so in a roundabout
way they are genetically just
predisposed to alcoholism
native here I have a membership card
so maybe because they never had any
cultural connection with the risks the
dangers the history of alcohol oh wait I
just saw Cam's comment Cam said I
suggested we get Damian Echoes on the
podcast a while ago he probably would
come that's that's the main character
from The West Memphis Three yeah
oh he's a real interesting guy yeah he's
so interesting he actually made it and
got married right yep I've heard him on
other podcasts are they still together
Kim uh I think so wow
he's such a smart interesting guy yeah
and as he grows up over the course of
the like 20 years he's in jail or more
you realize like what a thoughtful smart
sensitive dude it is and how much of a
shame that his whole life was
wasted and he's got permanent Trauma
from everything that went down it's
pretty sad yeah but with a happy ending
though everybody's yeah and Eddie from
uh stranger things is entirely based off
of him oh my shit's all wait what yeah
what do you mean like I mean just the
casino
they thought he was a murderer remember
he's fixing my camera thanks baby yes I
didn't know that yeah is he still
married to the girl from he is this is
her right oh that's crazy so cool and so
he got engaged to this woman
who started writing him she started
writing him because of what happened
while he was in jail she thought he was
innocent and they started falling in
love from like talking to each other in
letters he didn't know what she looked
like and she actually slays she's very
pretty yeah she's actually very pretty
quite frankly she slept but he didn't
even know what she looked like and so
they got married when he got out and
they've stayed together and they have a
family that's incredible he writes a lot
of books and stuff too he's a very
interesting oh maybe we should talk yeah
I mean that'd be fun I'd love to chat
with him
and I mean of course the other two guys
absolutely got their life's waist down
as well but he was considered to be like
the ring leader he was like the one
there yeah exactly they were giving him
like the worst accusations This was um
what was the name of it again
it was Paradise Lost Paradise Lost part
one through three you guys should watch
it this weekend if you're looking for
something good
all right on HBO let's okay you want to
talk about IVF
okay so well I wanted to read that one
comment but I wasn't able to find it
again I don't know if anybody can look
on the back end we'll move on it was
like earlier in the podcast
um but I love come up here I'm gonna do
a field sobriety test on you come on can
I sit here no you got a swim stand here
why would you you gotta come where is he
gonna sit why would you say that with
him
no he'll stand up it's all part of this
standing up what's why are you worried
about standing up since when is that a
problem I think it's best if I sit here
why is he turning a little red
you can't you don't know how to stand
are you trying to convince me yourself
is it a little red
are you are you genuinely trying to
convince me that you're sober and you
don't want to stand up he's probably
worried about the microphone there's not
enough for Mike over there no no no
we'll figure it out okay sure give me a
second give me a second well hold on
with this new office change we're kind
of capped on Mike so right yeah right
right no no it's fine we'll I'll just
give you directions you don't need the
money sure come on over here you sure
about that yeah you want me to come over
there
I'll come over
dude
yeah he's he's super sober look at that
look at his gate Ela that's a sober
man's gate right there
all right stand right here love
okay
okay so love are you drunk or sober
right now I'm very very sober you're
very sober right okay so first one thing
I want you to do sure oh Dan thank you
he's getting us a chair
it seems like you do need it I will sit
down all right so do one of these close
your eyes put one well put both hands
out finger pointing out like all the way
out like this
loosen your arm both hands like that now
touch your nose with one with your left
hand this is easy go ahead it's over
person no no no we'll adjust your left
hand love oh
okay now put your left hand back now do
your right hand nose okay
okay now start doing the alphabet
backwards please from Z
you can let you can you can let go your
nose now babies
I do not know the alphabet you're going
to jail right now by the way if you got
pulled over sure I mean I wouldn't
you're straight up going to jail brother
right
right you're spending a night in the
drunk tank my boy
I don't have a life so you're drunk I
don't have a license but you're saying
you're drunk if you're admitting to
drunk driving I don't have a license in
America so I take you over somewhere
that's not even true you drive a van
that I own
no I don't you don't no
then who's driving my van I don't know
it must be Jeremiah
yeah all right so like I could try any
one so can we get do we have anything I
want to get him to walk a line
do you guys see the
the chicks
cheeks are red because it's hot it is
very hot outside it's like 35 Centigrade
right interesting grades
[Laughter]
can we get a handheld camera I want to
make them walk the line
do you know you don't know the English
alphabet no no we use a different one in
Swedish I think it's the same letters
can you do the Swedish one
I don't know really if it's the same you
don't know the English alphabet and you
speak fluently can you do the Swedish
one
backwards
sure no okay regular irregular just do
the English alphabet the normal way sure
ABCD
klmh
[Music]
t
go again to the people been here but
that was correct
introduce Theodore versus love
but I actually don't know the alphabet
they never teach you in Sweden it's
weird in Sweden they don't really put
[Music]
I will say though in Israel I did know
the ABC but speaking I was not good at
so I do not know that ABC on Swedish
I learned the weekdays yeah you get by
15 years old
so I do have issues all right let me ask
you some questions yeah
ask me adult question
okay love yeah if a train is traveling
100 miles per hour sure
towards another train is on the same
track going 30 miles per hour right at
what speed will the two trains collide
200 200 yeah
y200
well I don't know if you multiply I mean
that's why I guess that's my guess based
on what a hundred times a hundred I said
a hundred one's going 100 and one's
going Thirty a hundred times
uh 100 times 100 is 10 000 I believe
right
30.
that's like three thousand
yeah
and how do you do how do you reach that
conclusion uh 100 times 30. and so and
so when trains travel their speed
multiplies
I mean that would be just my random
guess based on physiologically
physics do you think of Mike Moore make
more sense to approach it arithmetically
then then multiplicity I mean I do have
unfortunate news and I do not know what
that means right because I would what I
would say probably is correct is that a
hundred
plus thirty because it's not at times
because they're both going right they're
not they're not multiplying I have got
hit with the impact of 130. I had a
thought but then I was like damn I don't
really know
okay
and if you were sober do you think you
would have got that no no no no no no if
you were sober I'm I am sober right now
I wouldn't be able to drive a car
you would be able to drive a car oh yeah
let's go
we're staying in the parking lot let's
go bro we're going on the public street
now we're going let's go on the freeway
I mean why don't we just stay on the
park
here's love on the freeway right now
taking off on the 101 405 baby right
so love tell me you're right I'll tell
you
tell me this sure
what percentage of gas
greenhouse gas emissions are as a result
of livestock
Plus
you think it's 90 I think I'm at least
70. based on my research
okay he's he's so drunk you're trash bro
make me do some uh physical challenge
yeah well I need to I need a camera
otherwise they won't see it
yeah go go over by Dan please yeah well
you can you can actually hold it let's
put your coordination to the test
all right so here's love who he's just
been pulled over
the officer hold on love chill chill
wait for instructions oh I'm sorry wait
back up
okay wait for instructions all right
sure love just got pulled over right I
did get just to make sure that you're
good to drive love will you please walk
in a straight line where your heel
touches your toes each foot one after
the other I mean I don't mind doing that
just give me a second
right okay oh
he's doing it I like the pose oh oh I
think this personally would you think
you passed the test I mean
yeah you you just nailed it bro yeah
like a B minus is still passing all
right now give the mic to AV or Dan I
think the of course here let's do the
real one come back where you started
now here's how you really do it put both
hands out okay close your eyes
and and Heel To Toe
just focus it probably seems a little
bit inappropriate yeah
the police say I'm doing the test
I pull loose
go ahead
seems a little bit appropriate to close
your eyes when you're driving you're
going back
who's driving
yeah you're good bro you passed you
passed yeah no you did good I'm ready to
get you some heavy machinery brother oh
great great great
Charles is back in the shirt no no no no
no
I'm not done with him I'm not done
well I haven't decided yet I think he
might be sober physical exam I am sober
I am so good
all right sure now I want you to
close your eyes right put your left hand
out point it out
now angle it up just like 10 degrees
I'll put it out like this to the side
hold on I'm not going above 70 degrees
okay genocide no I'm not going about
seven no don't do it front do it to the
side like you were before when you press
your nose sure
okay now I didn't tell you to do that
this is proving prove myself now put
your finger in your ear
you don't have to go deep just okay now
put it in your other ear
stick your finger no no no no no no no
no
the left hand in the right here
okay
okay good
and now take the finger out and do this
[Music]
you follow me
no
no that's Bruce like
making fun of me well I don't know why
you think that I'm definitely not
I could do a car wheel I could do a
backflip really you're not asking me
anything
can you what about a summer song I'd see
a somersault you want to do a cartwheel
yeah a cartwheel would be fantastic I'd
love to see that yeah well what Dan
he'll do it right there where you're
standing maybe step to the side
this is dangerous considering your State
of Mind here but let's see
yeah right right right right
I'm ready to rescue
why
uh
do you want to stretch first
yeah get some stretches in
all right love is stretching he's
getting uh loosening his muscles for
this cartwheel
you know what I'm gonna go
yeah
no no no no this was your idea
I want the cartwheel
[Music]
I mean that's no no I mean you got it I
mean you know how you know the basic
motion of it
you got the basic motion of it down
well done thank you very much thank you
very much
workers comp everybody's saying
shack up my back I know that all right
love so right do we have a big reveal
here well I think me Eli should we push
all right let's let's talk and let's
lock in our answer here I'm a pretty
good actor I will say that
for a long time even before I got this
job so really look me in the eyes all
right right sure
get a close-up of his face look me in
the eyes
come go work get him face on Dan like
you can cover me just get let people see
his face
excuse me sir have you been drinking
tonight I have not been drinking tonight
and tonight it's been quite a wonderful
night with my friends we've been doing a
podcast
and we've been talking about talking to
Gabe you were drinking what
I have not been drinking anything I've
been drinking game results gamer Subs
sure well it smells a little bit like
alcohol in here sir that's odd because
it was at least two months ago I've been
drinking you've been drinking for two
months now eh it's been two months since
I was drinking so I want you to step out
the car here I'm gonna do some Fields
variety tests on you
of the guy being drunk and showing it
the what was it what's the sound bite
I mean I'm I'm tired yes
I do not have my idea on me it's in my
car okay yeah
and did someone have his keys by the way
he's not that he's not that drunk I mean
no you can still drive I can sit around
no you cannot I was saying I was saying
you're not Chapel's ID drunk
right that's like divorce from reality
drunks sure you should not you cannot
drive I mean I'm a good driver let's
just say that are you a better driver
drunk or something
depends on what kind of driving we're
talking about right right
and and so what kind of driving would be
better drunk kind of the fun driving the
fun kind yeah
right sure
what should we ask about Pokey
right
no secret channel do you do you Sim well
he didn't take a truth serum he's drunk
against the LIE mind you yeah he's
capable of lying Stone
um
all right let's lock it in I think he's
sober
really I mean I I think so I really
think he I think he's I think he's
acting no I think he passed all the
tests and he's totally fine yeah that's
all it does you know what about the
cartwheel
the cartwheel was well have you tried to
do a cartwheel review
you know what I mean we're not as young
as we used to be
he passed the sobriety test he looks
sober his eyes are nice and not glazed
over would you let him drive you home
right now absolutely not
I'm a good driver I have a new you've
mentioned that you've mentioned that a
few times in the past minute you're
right
all right let's I think he's drunk yes
yeah I mean I have to say uh we're
locking it in sure we're locking it in I
believe is drunk drunk
[Music]
six fussy what's it called again here
dude you're trying I am
Glam and Buzz ball I uh I'm drinking six
lemon bus bowl wait what's up they're
like little uh green grenades what yeah
they're like 15 alcohol a
um 150 milliliters I'll tell you this I
appreciate you taking
um The Challenge seriously you know
because usually these guys
that's what I preach because these guys
Dan comes out here he goes oh I'm high
yeah right before like
Uber home will Ethan pay for my Uber
back to work to get my car and he said
yes I was like it let's drink a
little bit yeah I'm not gonna make you
drive yeah but we're all going well
we're going up for Olivia's birthday
tonight to Saddle Ranch I don't know if
someone sent my timestamps I'm doing I
do the prime stance during the show it's
pretty bad oh no oh the timestamp maybe
Avery or someone's watching yeah Avery
usually got my every we're gonna need a
car lay down on the couch go ahead yeah
I think I'm fine I hope Michael pretty
well yeah okay
I want you to last through the night you
know what I mean I mean I I I hope my
uncle pretty well I'm a little worried
your face is really red is that normal
that's what you guys said
all right no I'm fine I'm fine just to
let you know pokeman's in chat oh
oh
yeah she heard her greatest simp was
being put through the ringer she came to
support what is this I've never seen
this before listen Pokey he's not a
drunk okay I do not drink this does not
represent love normally never drank
alcohol alone
dude I've never had is this like The
Craze right now this looks so cute pride
and true 15 percenters huh they're
really good so what's the like
total I've drunken I mean it's got to be
at least a shot in each one right yeah I
mean for sure
usually one drink's a shot they get you
bought in the can oh I see that right
well thank you love that was actually
really entertaining I appreciate that
I'm glad it was interesting yeah it was
great if you stop
and um right
how about a spicy chip now
I feel like are you trying to kill him
you already proven yourself on the space
yeah
you guys for watching the show's not
ending keep watching
well no it is it's ending the segment's
done
there's nothing left to say or do
[Music]
a well done love that was fantastic
[Applause]
next time you could do AFC hi Dan I want
you to see demons
I want you talking to Mitch McConnell's
Grim Reaper yeah next time we do how
high
guess who's High I want you seeing Death
Note keep her in the audience
hey love if you do get pulled over we
know a guy I will not be driving tonight
let's just say that if you do according
to David remember hit and run hit and
run baby
go drive away from the scene I've done
that already a couple times are you
drinking water love I hope you are lying
I'm not actually that drunk I'm fine
you're trash bro
anyway
well that was fun that was fantastic
wasn't it oh happy birthday Olivia by
the way
yeah
love is things on his desk are falling
over it's all good everything
everything's fine people everything's
fine happy birthday
tomorrow
and the age if I may ask I am 24. wow
it feels old 24. 24
the number what a beautiful name you
know it's such a beautiful number to be
it's like the greatest age 24. Brian
Kobe Bryant's number
Kobe for voting nope 24. yeah you made
it through 24. he didn't
no he did he did get past 24.
I don't know I don't know you know what
it was a dark joke nothing happened
moving along
um 24 is going to be a Slayer I feel 24
every year of your life is a Slayer oh
my God
sleigh life
um 24 wow it's like your body's still
working you can drink right do you feel
like death when you drink the next day
no see that's enjoyed
thank you and you probably don't feel
like death when you eat like one
um McMuffin probably too yeah a muffin a
McMuffin gives me like sustenance I feel
like yeah cause if I eat a McMuffin I
feel like I'm dying I feel like
everything changes when you like reach
30 years old and older
32 maybe maybe 28 there's a little
sneaking in of like
vulnerability poison
oh damn Kobe died in your wedding day I
think we heard that before
never forget wow it's kind of like in a
sense anytime uh brings up Kobe in a
sense you can really just be like love
you babe yeah no it's cool it's a good
reminder every year
yeah it's cool huh we're up to the goat
rip to the goat number 24. cheers my
dude 24 and there's so much more yes
somebody in Chad said that's a Neil
Young Lyric
oh it is old man is the name of the song
Oh man oh man I'm a lot like you
alrighty got any big plans
Saddle Ranch Saddle Ranch there's the
ranch
gonna Ranch that bit is there a weight
limit on the saddle
there's got to be probably I think that
you're totally I did lose are you
kidding you're oh no no you're right
you're good for that it would be like
400 pounds because real horses have a
lightweight limit of like 250. and I was
right there I I for a minute I couldn't
ride a horse I remember where was that
what a tragedy there was something for a
minute Ethan couldn't get up on that
stuff they're like don't dude you're
gonna break that horse what and
think back in the day horses used to
like lug nights on Armor and and I
still weigh more than them oh is it from
Nathan for you that's why we know it so
good Nathan for you he uh yeah
you guys are everybody's seen that show
but yeah he made he he made a special uh
horseback riding for for fat people yes
where he would put like weather balloons
on the horse to reduce the weight it was
so awesome
approximately 20 of a horse's weight
yeah that's how much they can hold sorry
I cut off the first sentence okay so if
they're a massive horse because some of
the horses got real big
mm-hmm
just the right height
some might say all right listen
we have done nothing
yeah should we get to the first link in
the dock let's see it's only an hour and
uh 18 minutes into the shows when
there's no sponsor I feel like nothing
keeps me organized
uh play the cash do you have a cash
sound um Zach
yeah just play that this is Spencer's
playing my sound to promote their
product
wait I think it's muted also
also Spencer's owes me money now
I don't know
it says when you're shopping at
Spencer's with your also
with your parents and stray a little too
far I don't know
oh I know
it's kind of a weird one
people loved it though it got a lot of I
think they have like dildos or something
there right okay
very funny Spencer's gonna cost you
though foreign
[Applause]
that's my right to publicity that's my
voice if you're gonna sell dildos with
my voice I'm getting paid
that's right
um
that's the belt Spencers
tolls for you
I feel like I'm drunk by proxy love you
got me drunk just by being near me I was
horrible about contacting
uh this is a fantastic story and I was
even like we have to make sure that this
is actually this person because it's so
outrageous okay Demi Lovato's sister
okay okay
Madison de la oh she doesn't have the
same last name
probably a stage name
stage name
I think they have different dads oh okay
different dads I mean double check that
makes sense now Demi Lovato of course
was the subject of some
a ridicule of our on our end but I I
think it was fairly warranted and at
very least it was very funny she is of
course uh known for the yogurt
the yogurt incident
the uh her favorite yogurt store had
diet yogurt in front or she had diet
products in front and it made her it
ruined her whole week because it made
her think about dieting or something you
have that sound go ahead Zach he's in
the restroom oh
well it sounds something like this
I don't remember
so here is Demi Lovato's sister
and this is from geez this is from
yesterday
so this is still a fresh wound and the
Lovato family
I've been seeing a lot of support for
Ethan Klein and Trisha Paytas recently
[Music]
oh you're back can you play the whole oh
that's a b
I know man life is life is really hard
it's given like fousey after nobody
wanted to like wait in line for him to
get him coffee and then he goes and
Rambles about like Society
my thing was like a kid in Sudan who was
in like had a grain of food in
like two weeks and then he go and then
he they're like get a load of this
oh you moved
I had a hard time with the rest of the
week I didn't get the yogurt I wanted I
didn't want Zach to see me there so I
just dipped and they're like uh and the
kid in Africa who's starving is like
yeah man I just feel so bad for her
so she says I've been seeing a lot of
support for Ethan Klein and Trisha
Paytas slightly I mean thank you
I don't know I don't know what she's
talking about Trisha's been getting
support I guess why because of the
Colleen stuff I don't know
let's not forget the things they have
both done to undermine multiple
communities
and I will never forget what they said
about my sister it seems your problem
with us is your sister
I don't let me know why am I put in a
bucket with Trisha she has harmed she's
the community harmer she's like Mrs
um
you know I she's hot she's harmed the
Jewish people that's my community
and then I had a hard time and then I
had a hard time the rest of Yom Kippur
what about undermining communities what
well people I've heard a lot of people
say about Trisha with like the the beat
well I'm not talking about Dad I'm
talking about you
who's right I'm trying to explain
so people have said about like her
saying that she's trans people have said
about her saying that she has a boredom
or or no but this is
talking about you I'm setting up so that
I can go back to myself let's go to
yourself so so then if we're gonna say
mult I've I've undermined multiple
communities and undermining says to me
again to go back to Trisha it's like you
infiltrated it
and parroted it
use it for your own gain almost like a
cultural appropriation but not you know
what I mean and so she's done that to
the Jewish people as well bruh
and so we get to the yourself part
because I'm not listening
right and so when I I don't know I can't
I like obviously I've done and said
really offensive things
that I've you know had to reckon with
and come to term with you know things
that are very deeply embarrassing and
deeply shameful that it did happen
and that's something that I'm you know
but but I don't know what communities
I've undermined that's giving me a
little too much credit I feel like like
I've said racist insensitive culturally
insensitive even xenophobic I would say
at a certain point uh horrible things
but to say I undermined them seems to be
an overreach hmm
speaking of overreach I would say the
short Community maybe yeah okay that's
fair I may have undermined the short
Community okay Stolen Valor friends
that's a hard time the rest of the
weekend and I mean don't get me started
with the Croc lifts
it's all over for the little ones for
the Little Kings
Little Kings get these Croc lips bro
change your life
so I don't know but but what's
interesting to me is that like
by saying this
she's revealing like that the yogurt
jokes really got to
Demi
but that's just it's kind of insane to
put it all on you and Trisha I mean the
whole internet was talking about the
yoga joke that was like a whole I was
trying to dig viral yeah for everybody
talking about it I was trying to dig
deep I was like
what have I said
about
about Demi
what's the name of her move her her
[Music]
Duty
I'm trying to think did I say anything
else because like
if it's just the yogurt thing I don't
get it
but I I frankly
I couldn't think of anything right I
mean yeah I was looking through uh
potential links and I kept coming back
to just the clip of you guys talking
about the frozen yogurt I mean does she
not like that that we showed this I mean
I'm sorry Demi but like
this is awesome Demi has totally
acknowledged poop before so why so then
what did I do what did I do
I think she looks stunning it's amazing
it's edited and it's perfect it's not
it's not oh wait it was edited didn't we
conclude it was edited yeah
my wife went out for yogurt
what have I done to You Demi Lovato to
enrage your sister so she will never
forgive me
just like you will never forgive the
yogurt store
we hold on we hold those grudges
do we have the clip
what clip I wanted to watch
what we said there's a clip go look for
the clip I wanted to see I mean
like here here is um now there is this
one clip okay okay so so here here's the
original tweet it has 640 likes so
people are I guess
um the top response is oh my God wait
what did they say about Demi how did I
miss that I don't know I missed it too I
bet I think I feel more bad for the
small business she blasted for having
sugar-free options that's true she did
get that that store that she named that
dared to have sugar-free yogurt uh they
were getting a ton of and like one
star reviews and stuff that's why I
don't understand why is this so much
about you when it was just a big story
everybody talked about it like unless
there's something I'm not thinking of
which might be possible there I might
owe the Lovato family an apology I might
I will keep looking this weekend you
know and if that's the case Madison then
I will humbly submit to you all my own
dude
that you guys can do due to what you
will with
or if you want to bury the hatchet we
can go get yogurt together
sugar yogurt me you and your sister Talk
Shop
I'll I'll even contact the yogurt store
ahead of time and have them like there's
no problem that it was all sugar free
options so the sugar-free option
triggered her that's what you're Oh I
thought the opposite which is kind of
interesting because like there's
diabetic people that actually would die
if they didn't have that or and didn't
get the yogurt that I wanted I think the
Curtis the criticism in her mind was
that
she I guess has a an eating disorder or
struggle or she struggled with their
weight and so she did grow up within
yeah with an eating disorder she talked
about it a bunch and so seeing the diet
food made her think like
it yeah triggered her not sure
it's I mean it's a certainly a valid
experience for her to have it's just not
the world debatable whether or not you
should blast it to the world and blast
the business that's definitely not
debatable yeah that's what I'm saying
but maybe maybe Demi's little sister
would debate it with us well wait
there's something else that just came up
we talked about her story of her being
abducted by aliens
yeah
yeah she said she was abducted by aliens
and on the spaceship they also had
sugar-free yogurt and it was really
traumatic I've never really made a joke
about that the anal probing wasn't even
the worst part of it that wasn't all the
enemies though that was way later so I
don't think that they should come
talking to him because I feel like
this story shouldn't be something they
hold on to so much anger like that you
know that's what's so interesting this
is from yesterday yeah and so it's kind
of weird like Demi must also be really
emotional about this though
we should hash it out who what
communities have I undermined Madison
the Froyo communities
I'm Pro Froyo girl
me too and if you come in my yogurt
store I'm gonna be fro yo throwing yo
ass up
right now dude that was solid thank you
brother
let's look at the quote tweets here
amen okay Amen brother wait that's
another Lovato
Dallas Lovato
wait
is there is there another family member
in on this oh no the whole family
there's another one that's all family
hates us
another one that's I didn't even know
that amen she was in her documentary
the Lovato's are sitting around talking
about me and Trisha still we should
watch the clip all right well I'm glad I
checked that though wow apologies to the
Lovato whole Lovato family just because
Ethan Trisha deal with terrible people
themselves doesn't mean they aren't
terrible people too
just most people in the YouTube drama
podcast space of YouTube are terrible
okay okay Sam
yes Sam that's cool I mean yeah
that's fine I I accept that
uh who is Sam well here I read the next
one she says wait oh my God I love H
Street Productions one of the things I
like about him is he always willing to
admit and take responsibility when he's
wrong about something I don't remember
him saying thing about Demi though okay
so maybe and thank you by the way thank
you
to her somebody comments about froyogain
I saw that too I mean so many people
dogged on them during that time that's
what I'm saying I'm sure if Ethan knew
more about Demi now he'd have a lot more
respect for her
[Music]
um
that's debatable yeah I don't know and
and and I mean I don't know what is
there to know I don't know much about
her I did recently watch one of her docs
and she's been through so much she has
been through a lot so maybe you're right
maybe you're right I'm being facetious
well the yogurt thing it's still wrong
it's sorry I mean the yogurt thing it's
hard to it's silly though silly yes yeah
and so I appreciate you the heart of
Demi oh you so you're like a hardcore
Santa okay well thank you for um going
against your your star there in support
of the truth
you're true you're an Ethan truth
that's bravery all right so let's see
what the did we say
uh here and and by the way I'm in The
Mask
so it's from the Frenemies era also
that's so old now it's from years ago
and look at my dumb ass
Europe you cannot get offended what this
guy says about you somebody stop me you
just can't
so uh Demi Lovato Lovato Lovato she said
I'm finding it extremely hard this is
some Karen ass to be honest yeah
found it extremely hard to order from
Froyo from this place when you have to
walk past tons of sugar-free cookies and
other diet foods before you get to the
counter do better what is she what is
she mad about diet culture vultures what
is she mad about she's mad because it
triggers her because she had an eating
disorder okay so what the world needs to
organize around you but like so what get
the diet food I don't understand the
appreciation no she's saying she's diet
food should not even well I gotta stop
and talk about how good that outfit is
yeah that mask
that's definitely one thing I do miss
about Frenemies it was so much fun it
was so hype and trust me I hate waking
up early but I did it and I did like
hours of makeup and boy
that is good because it's promoting like
eating disorders and telling people they
need to be skinny don't you know there's
diabetes diabetic people
sugar-free desserts
what's wrong with
oh I'm gonna go potty
um we're having some technical issues
here
but but again if there's something else
I I would happily issue an apology a
retraction whatever it needs to get into
the good graces of the lovados
you know
they can hear it okay I'll just play the
audio then for you here
wanting sugar I don't get it she also
promoted teami which is a detox tea
just like try to make you lose weight
fast by you know oh that's good yeah so
she's awesome
there's a photo of her with her little
tea her little dude what is wrong with
you well the problem is that she tagged
do better please I don't even know what
the you're on about but now all of
her lackeys went and dislike bombed this
poor wrestling oh that's that's shitty
like it's one thing to have like an
opinion about it but also well she
tagged them and so now all over
fans I mean again
a hundred percent I think you were in
the right I mean whatever
like they destroyed this business for
what
for I still don't understand frankly
like I still don't really understand why
she was upset
there's sugar-free options everywhere
you go
why did she call out this one specific
yogurt store I I I don't get the the
whole theory on this
time the rest of the weekend
um
I wish Ethan knew Demi's not the victim
here he shouldn't feel bad was she the
new Demi's not the okay yeah thank you
so I don't know
I thought but I'm definitely tickled by
the fact that the whole Lovato family is
speaking out against us
I don't I don't think I need to get
lumped in with Trisha you know what I
mean
I've never said I'm a chicken nugget
I just have it
true it's true not yet not yet who knows
how I feel tomorrow yeah I'll be true to
myself no matter how I wake up tomorrow
that's true
chatter saying take Ella's hint
okay hold on hold on let me let me let
me read this
Chatters saying take Elis hint or
projecting your feelings on the other
stop you're literally not iwa or Ethan
they're a married couple who know each
other's boundaries stop being weird
thank you Mega awesome
that's refreshing I hear wavery shut
your mouth you're not God
oh my god oh Bagel boss call back
love that
been watching your clips for a while and
can finally support the channel thanks
for keeping me up to date on all the tea
also Olivia's uh PowerPoints are Fire
Edition exactly my wheelhouse well
speaking of which I think it's I think
it's time
[Music]
we're time to go so so I guess we'll
wait for ELO to come back but it did the
feed get fixed Dan it did okay great yep
so
um as we wait for Ila's return
uh check out Dan's self-aware this
is so cursed bro
why does this exist I hate it
so what is this there's an image of you
and then they put it in something and
try to get you to move around I guess I
don't know this is what we had to do to
get him out of the chair actually
that's definitely the sound it's making
kill me I don't really like it
um
lots of people on the subreddit have
been
uh making really interesting
PowerPoint suggestions
this one actually we are preparing for
yes yes but some of the other ones uh
we're also preparing for Israel and
Palestine drama that one I'm really
taking my time with that is so tea right
now it is so tea right now let me know
when you do that one so I could call in
sick for sure for sure can I call in
sick too yeah yeah just Olivia I'll give
a dissertation yeah
girl I have the latest t on this Israel
Palestine girl it's been crazy this week
Olivia please do a PowerPoint on the
assassination of Arc Duke Franz
Ferdinand that exactly would be
fascinating
yeah I mean I can't talk about that one
enough it changed the world the shot
that changed the world right
irrevocably forever so where there's a
lot this there's a lot of tea to spill
on that one Olivia please make a
PowerPoint on the Big Bang
always relevant
this is very this is also I mean I love
this stuff so do you know anything about
Quantum fluctuation well you can learn
yeah yeah I do a lot of big stuff
happening in um gravity waves lots of
big stuff happening big news on the
gravity front yeah the news with the
Stars too
a lot we're getting Graphics the
gravity's coming and it's literally
waves that's true there's big uh
scientific breakthrough and grab
gravitational uh waves yeah
two black holes emerge together really
and blasted gravity waves through the
whole universe is that true yeah that's
yeah and they're they're able to measure
it now and um they're I guess getting
learning a lot about physics from it I'm
not really clear on the science I am
after all just some guy
that stuff is none of my business
well it is your business now that stuff
is all my business
Olivia do a PowerPoint on the
Revolutionary War lots of tea That's
cold tea That's cold tea no no but there
is lots of tea involved literally yeah
okay I think that they were trying to do
a little
this isn't the Boston Tea Bar this is
George Washington right right about led
up to you know what I'm saying this
attack no type no taxation
Olivia please do a PowerPoint on Imaging
of quantum confinement and electron wave
interference I did that one already hey
you see Ian and I are actually did I
love uh
I love you guys on this so much
okay somebody said do a PowerPoint about
the Tupac murder
wow I don't know if okay I'm qualified
what about the JFK assassination here's
am I qualified I mean I would love to
here's the Boston Tea Party so they got
their own one here and so that we have
our cue is all
that wants to be very short if I just
did the Boston Tea Party here's the T
they threw it in the water here's the T
it's there there it is
um Okay so
uh let's do the PowerPoint okay oh
so without further Ado let me open this
up
morally I'm feeling weird about this one
I love I love Ariana Grande
what do you love about her
I think she's one of the most talented
people in the business right now I think
she knows what she's doing she knows
um
she knows she she layers all her music
she mixes everything she's incredible
she I will say she's super taunted her
voice is stunning yeah she is so
immaculate and it's also she proves
everybody wrong when they're like she's
lost all of her technique no she brings
it right back and like she has proven
that she is fit to play Glinda in this
in the wicked movie so let's say we
stand we stand so hard but then let's
talk about this well let's we can
preface by saying this
her Talent is not in question here
correct no right absolutely not her
character hadn't really been in question
before I think that she's
I've watched interviews with her forever
I think that she's hilarious lover this
is the first time I'm like oh no
so
so here we go
um this is all the gossip right now yeah
and uh go ahead uh Olivia I'll all right
go ahead this is based on Ian tweet
don't break up with your wife I'm not
bored
she has a song called break up with your
girlfriend I'm bored this is the story
about Ariana Dalton Gomez Ethan Slater
and Lily J dude I'm sick of people named
Ethan
this one was funny because it's Ethan
and Slater from yeah right people I
there's like a whole wave of people
named Ethan who are douches really I
think so and I'm sick of it when I was a
kid I never knew anything growing up
huh
and now I gotta deal with this all
the time
next slide people doing like this
our players is Ari we know who Ariana
Grande we love her
yes Ariana Grande is married to Dalton
Gomez
um they started dating early 2020. he is
a real estate agent he uh that's that
that
that sounds really bad for him why he
real estate agents are the worst people
in the world they just aren't they're a
different breed man
um it before all of this it seemed like
they had a very private happy Sweet
marriage they dated all through
quarantine they got married in 2021
this was an interesting thing was this
her next relationship after Pete
Davidson
she yes
briefly maybe was hooking up with one of
the guys from social house and then this
is her first like big relationship okay
because with every time they got engaged
yeah
um October or something and um how did
she meet this real estate agent he took
her he toured her around a house are you
serious contacted not him but someone
was like she thought he was cute what he
closed the deal in two senses whoa so
that's really interesting because when
you watch those real estate
um we've never seen like a cute realtor
boy or girl
um we've never seen a cute realtor have
we that's so funny
no comment no comment okay I guess
they're all they're all all I'm trying
to do is like in real life it's nothing
like the shows no they're all weird
horse like one was like a horse woman
remember the lady who sold us our first
house
oh yeah
there's this agent you showed us our
first house
just by default we didn't know anybody
we were looking online for an agent I
think we found her just by like calling
a random number yeah and getting a lead
so her license plate was like I'd rather
be on my horse she's that type of girl
um I'd rather be on my horse she's a
little I don't know was it what was it
exactly but it was something with Horus
well she had one she had a bumper
sticker yeah so anyway she was fine I
mean like I said agents I'm like they
don't do anything and in LA and now with
uh real estate prices going up they make
so much money and they're like literally
don't do anything okay so anyway so
Ariana hold on this there's one thing
there's one little part left so she
sells us our first house
I don't think that she bought a house
from him because one of the lyrics she
dropped an album during quarantine
called positions that was pretty much
all about him one of the lyrics is um I
ain't trying to sign a lease I'm just
gonna make you my home which is I think
you
okay
next so we sell the house
then this was we we moved to our second
house okay so we bought a second house
I'm sorry that uh you know to be flexing
out here but this is just important to
the story okay
and so we get a different agent one that
we're working with now that we like one
that was recommended to us so yeah she
was recommended by personal yeah and so
and so I get an email from this old
agent
and she's pissed she goes how could you
not
how could you not include me how dare
you don't call me after everything we've
been through together
yeah and then she started being like
I'll do anything to get she started I
felt like she was propositioning me to
be totally honest
he's like I'll do anything to get that
commission she said that I don't
remember yeah I'll do anything to get
that commission I've seen that movie
I was so weird I hadn't thought about
this woman in years
and then of course don't get me started
on Zach's Tad
I've talked I've already talked the
cat's out of the bag on the toddster
but uh that's my experience with agents
we're with one now that we like she's
very sweet
anyway agents that's the my take on
Asians thank you these are their wedding
photos from 2021
very sweet
but the fact that she got together with
her agent this is like something that
never happens because like when you
watch These reality shows about age like
it's always Sunset they're it's like a
super it's usually really beautiful
young women I don't really see like
studs usually so I'm selling sounds yeah
because it's all women and so they're
always trying to like flirt with the
guys but never hooking up with the
client
but that whole show is like fictional it
makes no sense I've never seen a realtor
look like one of those girls never
well you know what's funny I've gone to
look at places represented by their
company and it's like it's not them I
was like is it gonna be one of the girls
no it's some old horse lady and no
offense I mean you could be beautiful
and old and also beautiful and ride
horses that is so correct yeah okay
anyway that's enough about agents so he
did it he did The Impossible yeah
they look happy
yeah yeah they oh my God this is our
next player his name is Ethan Slater aka
Mr Bob Mr Bob meaning this man
played SpongeBob on Broadway and he's
brilliant I'll say it he was brilliant
okay yeah so I can see that they would
they um probably
connected a lot on on the musical side
of things yes we will the way they meet
is via that so if you go to the next one
I'm still looking at this photo I'm
taking it in and I'm not making any
comments
we're just taking it in that's all in
the story we don't know yeah okay
no relation yeah right yes
oh relationships do you know this guy
Ian cousin I do not know this individual
once removed
it looks like he doesn't brush enough
and like that's actually that's my
that's the thing that's standing up okay
let's hold off though let's let's listen
to the story the gums look too dark and
the teeth a little yellow and I'm maybe
I'm being too judgy but I just get the
sense of this man's breath smells
are a little yellow oh
we get later in the story we don't like
him later okay all right let's let's get
he looks like more smelly gums
so this is him in SpongeBob the musical
okay um he was
he was the whole production was
brilliant they closed way too soon
um he was nominated for a Tony wait why
did they close did people stop watching
I think that people didn't really give
it a chance people weren't buying
tickets it was very uh that got
copyright claimed oh okay but um it was
really self-aware very technical very
funny
it was good is it for adults or for kids
both okay
okay so he's the star he's attacked he's
the triple threat yeah
he is married just needs to brush more
yeah
you hear that Ethan
later
um he's married to Lily J
um they met in high school their High
School sweethearts they've been together
15 years they've been married before
that's beautiful yeah and they have a
seventh month old baby beautiful yeah
that's that's that's so lovely seven
months seven months okay one of the
things I love is when
I think it's very cool and speaks to a
good character when there's a couple
that has been together before one or the
other success right and they stay
together
I think that that always makes me
endeared to that person yeah so I love
it what hell yeah brother oh yeah just
like you right AB
s
you know
is that what yours is that what yeah
yeah and one of the reasons why we look
up to you guys same thing oh you're are
you complimenting us I thought you were
complimenting yourself both okay
a b hasn't changed man he came out to LA
he's still the good old boy he was
just a b from Detroit
shouts out so anyway what an inspiring
story two lovers yes so this is photos
and a short Legend too wow yeah
well she's wearing heels that's true how
tall is he can we google that I can't
Google that
I mean I don't again like I know where
this is going so I'm kind of primed for
it but he's giving lollipop you want to
guess I actually don't know where this
is going but I'm guessing already where
it's going he's like 5'3
dude he's straight Lollipop Guild in
this he's five seven you
you will be interested to know that he
does indeed play a munchkin
in Wicked oh yeah so he literally is a
lollipop kid he does not play a lollipop
kid he plays a munchkin and Alice in
wonder or in the The Wicked we'll get to
it wait and I'm not following
what's it called The Wizard Of The
Wizard of Oz he's literally in The
Wizard of Oz world as yes a munchkin yes
in the world that's a fantastic
yes what a cast that's right on the nose
man
Okay so
more of them because they've been
together 15 years so they have a lot of
photos they look really happy yeah
so the wicked movie
the cast list comes out who's on it
Ariana Grande is playing Glinda that is
so exciting that's so amazing who's
playing bach bach is Ethan Slater who's
Ethan Slater oh he was in the SpongeBob
musical it's going to be great so she
does musicals what's that she does
musically she started on Broadway in 13
The Musical by Jason Robert Brown one of
the best ones he started on Broadway wow
I had no idea oh dude Broadway singers
are like the most talented yeah if you
listen to the soundtrack I listened to
the soundtrack when I was like before
Ariana was on Victorious I just listened
to it wow voice is so beautiful that's
so brand new you if you guys want to
listen to that okay I I I'm impressed I
mean wow that she was like 14 15. wow
wow yeah so she got discovered from
there she was on Victorious the
Nickelodeon show and then via Victoria's
she launched her pop career obviously
and Glinda is which character in this
the pink witch the pink witch the cute
funny bubbly pink the nice witch yeah
in Wicked
yeah got it okay and then Bach is here
if you go to the next slide who is Bach
to Glinda and wicked he's a munchkin and
he is obsessed and in love with Glinda
like that's his character and then
Glinda like pawns him off to someone
else okay wow yeah and so Bach is a main
character in the play Bach is a big
character yeah okay like a supporting
player
and he plays a munchkin huh yeah and
then actually Bach is the one who turns
into the Tin Man
sorry to spoil it wait he transforms
into tin man this is the or Wicked is
the origin story for Wizard of Oz really
oh that's special yeah that's I like
that it's like why is the wicked witch
so wicked that's basically what it's
about okay like that concept yeah
so popular
okay all right timeline December 2022
Ariana Grande moves to London to shoot
the wicked movie shouts out London that
actually looks awesome wow oh my God the
beans on toast yeah that does look good
y'all get me some of that so huge no no
the beans on top
stop it looks it looks fantastic I was
talking about the book wait okay I need
to know more details so this is a show
that's already been out it's been out
for a long time wicked it's a musical
that has been out and on Broadway for a
long time
but they're making a film adaptation of
it yeah got it so this one so she is
shooting the film adaptations correct
okay when this all went down on set okay
yeah got it fine now we're in London and
we're about to start filming should we
be watching this movie
December 2024. is this drama going to
get in the way of your enjoyment of it
no hell no no
I won't let it
do we are we gonna bring popcorn and
throw it at the screen when he's on
screen no we're gonna sit our asses down
we're gonna listen okay
all right
next
trouble in Paradise
in April some fans were starting to
notice that we hadn't heard much news
about Dalton we hadn't seen them
together they hadn't been posting and
then if you go to the next slide Ariana
was posting
or no the next slide I read this
headline Ariana Grande Ariana Grande fan
suspects singer and husband Dalton Gomez
he's a singer
no she's a singer the spec singer her
and husband the husband and him oh
Dalton Gomez are headed for a divorce
after spotting social media Clues yes so
before I show you the social media Clues
okay in August so we're in April right
now
August the summer before she posted a
tick tock where in it she was not
wearing her ring and she looks at the
camera and she's like I'm not getting a
divorce stop it so because she said that
it quieted down a lot of fans and they
were like maybe like she did that video
remember so if you pull that up I have
that video
but her comment uh uh slowed the gospel
I'm just not wearing my ring it's
getting cleaned I'm not getting a
divorce before you start don't
she's talking with the English accent
yeah just for like fun and just for
sillies Christmas sillies and stuff
so there yeah it seems like she's trying
to make a statement right yeah I mean
that could be unrelated probably yeah
well if she was getting a divorce she
probably wouldn't have said that yeah
right except we do know that Colleen
Ballinger posted on Twitter that summer
that she went to film her show she
posted photos and was like see we're not
getting a divorce and then
overcompensating perhaps
there is interesting parallels between
this situation and Colleen's okay
in in
that aspect of Colleen's life romantic
aspect absolutely
and did I understand that right that
they're friendly they did know each
other when Ariana was on Broadway in 13
when she was 14 15 years old she
performed in club I don't know if they
performed more than once but there's at
least one time they performed in a club
together when Ariana was a teenager oh
crazy
next
next okay these are the clues that
they're talking about via social media
I mean I agree with this statement I
don't always wear my wedding ring I just
don't think it's a big deal I don't I
literally never like it's just a jewelry
to me it doesn't mean I have to wear it
every single day so that's why people
were like um
it's nothing I because I yeah it's so
stupid when people take it so seriously
like oh my God she doesn't have a
wedding ring on yeah
some people get insecure I guess that
they're like oh why aren't you wearing
your wedding are you trying to get dudes
to talk to you
which is crazy if that's the case
there's a problem in their relationship
yeah if you're counting on the Ring The
Ring is gonna stop you the ring is gonna
stop people not the person not the wife
the ring if they don't approach her then
she'll never cheat yeah you know Colleen
was in thank you next the music video
when she was not pregnant with Flynn
yeah
what because Ariana pulled all her like
friends to be in the video so they are
friends it was a big event yeah right
they were friendly no I didn't know that
okay yes
they haven't since then the music video
comment or interact that's crazy to me
can you call that I like this now
I'll say uh to wedding ring
um theorist yeah I have never worn my
wedding band and I'm happy to report not
one woman has ever hit on me in that
time yeah
well I would like to disprove that
theory right now
so
all you basically if you don't want
anyone approach you you just don't
shower
she opens the video don't do your hair
she's in the first shot it's a line yeah
well that's bestie that's a bestie spot
that's the hero spot crazy yeah I think
they gave it to her because she's
pregnant and it like went with it but
yes she does open it which is crazy
yeah how did I not know that
oh wow
that's mad respect that is wild okay
okay I like to pick her brain about
what's going on here okay what's
Happening Here
I think I did I skip forward too much
yeah you did okay just go to tennis game
to end all tennis games Okay okay so
suddenly happy
Ariana is spotted post-strike at
Wimbledon with um on either side she has
Andrew Garfield and then her um co-star
Jonathan Bailey who plays her actual
boyfriend in Wicked okay he plays the
boyfriend in Wicked people didn't know
much about Jonathan Bailey he is gay and
he does have a husband but people didn't
know that when they went so
um due to all the writers being on
strike all the actors in London were
free to go to Wimbledon together
um at the game which was photographed
heavily like both personally and
professionally they like we saw photos
from both Ari was spotted without her
ring hanging with everybody and some
people on Twitter thought that maybe she
was like
like showing the hand a little bit more
because she was like can people please
notice
I don't think so that seems like a reach
I don't know especially considering the
Instagram she made I mean I think she
already made it clear the wedding ring
is not a big statement for her right she
doesn't always wear it however What
followed this okay makes me think that
this was a move you know right next
so people thought that Jonathan Bailey
was uh potentially her love interest but
now he is he is gay I can see I can see
yeah I can see why interpretation
so the next day Ariana and Dalton
divorce news drops
um they have separated and they are
heading for divorce and Insider told TMZ
Ariana Grande and Dalton Gomez have
separated our heading for divorce now
how long were they married since uh
spring 2021
can I give uh Selena some unsolicited
advice Ariana
Ari I don't know why I'm so sorry
because they both
I am so so sorry about that you guys uh
to Ari I want to give some unsolicited
advice she seems to like
run into this idea of marriage oh quick
you know it was the P thing we're
getting married then the next guy she's
getting married you know how old is she
30 oh yeah no you no your time your
clock is ticking girl never mind
she looks younger I agree that's it she
looks really young I didn't hear what
you said I said your clock is sticking
but I asked a joke that's rude I take it
all back but well I will say is you know
spend a little more time with them maybe
what she said you're hearing that yeah
okay oh God is he sick
oh my God what what happened
oh no yeah he's he's been in the
bathroom for a bit holy I don't
know bro you didn't have to go that hard
oh my God
is he okay there
yeah they're trying to talk to him right
now but he's not being very uh you know
you well make sure you may have to fix
another door in the office Jesus yeah he
won't open the door he just responded
somebody got it oh he just responded
there's no one in there he just
responded he's okay okay somebody I want
eyes on him to make sure he's fine Jesus
that's dedication to the show my friends
Tim's over there now with him
I just want eyes on him to make sure
he's okay
someone needs to keep an eye on him so
he's got his phone with him
yeah he's got his phone in Sam's over
there with him and okay uh with their
with the okay well just thank you to Sam
okay
but let us know if anything
yeah okay so they're getting divorced
okay
yes
next then that day Ariana deletes all
her wedding photos from her social media
that's sad so that's why people were
like girl just wanted us to see that she
didn't have a ring I wonder did they
have a messy breakup or do you just not
leave something like that up I assume
that it's messy
um Also earlier in the year Dalton
Dalton quickly deleted his Instagram so
people are like maybe he was just
deleting his Instagram I don't know
that's pretty dressed yeah and then this
day she deleted the wedding photos
[Music]
just sent in WhatsApp he said I'm all
good LOL I'm doing time stamps in here
all right buddy
I'll drink something get some coffee or
water water
no more grenades or whatever those green
shits are called
he's doing okay he's got water ask him
if he wants some Chupa Loompas or
something I could get him some Taco Bell
if it makes him feel better
I'll message him
you got me
is dating a cast mate two days later
what's up yeah two days later so soon
after she is dating a cast mate that guy
not that one okay hold the phone no
that's too quick
hold the phone
they went public with their relationship
they didn't go public it was reported on
so I you'll see later until this is
absolutely positively confirmed I will
not I will not
change my mind about how I feel about
people about Ariana Grande so this I
know everything this isn't 100 confirmed
yet it's news out like six news outlets
and like reputable ones are they would
not be reporting on this if they didn't
feel confident enough because they still
want to be in like Cahoots with Ariana
Grande's Insider like they would not be
doing this if it were absolutely
positively false so it's someone close
to her is leaking this to the Press
that's usually how it works yeah oh yeah
yeah like friends like these yeah jeez
all right so I made an Ethan Slater life
mood board
um I have baby I have SpongeBob I have
wedding and I have dangerous women by
Ariana Grande do you want to break this
down
yeah so Ethan Slater does indeed need
have a wife of they've been together 15
years a wife of four he did indeed play
SpongeBob in SpongeBob the musical he
was brilliant we talked about it and
they have a freshly newborn yes newborn
seven months old now which means when
they moved to London in December newborn
evil yeah
and then Ariana Grande which that's a
serve song
how could you do this SpongeBob yeah
you is sand what why cheat on Sandy
She's Everything You Ever Wanted the way
the chat is trying to tell me that I
don't know the hugest part of this story
we will get there she knows everything
shame on you guys have faith you think
Olivia became the pp Queen by leaving
out the most important details oh then
maybe that didn't sound doesn't sound
good oh they're saying the wife is the
one who confirmed it
that happened the world was drafted Rock
coming up okay so so I have a thesis
next that I will take you guys through
because I was feeling a lot of uh I was
like I had a lot to say okay chat don't
spoil it
um but yes Ian walked so that Olivia
could run I think oh hush or maybe maybe
even I mean Ian
so that Olivia could run Ethan Slater is
too close
your problem the only reason you're so
good at PowerPoints is because you stand
on the shoulder of the giant before you
one million pounds later are you kidding
Keith's the one who taught me about
making I was like how do I make it cuter
and he was like you need color
oh good advice Ian yep and I implemented
yep
I'm like the old car in Cars and she's
Lightning McQueen and I'm like okay let
me tell you a kid literally not easy out
there so you had a mentor
yeah he's Yoda he's a PowerPoint mentor
okay so before we get to my thesis okay
A lot of people are like why is
everybody ripping Ariana Grande apart
why are they not ripping the husband
apart one million thousand percent he is
in the negative negative of this
situation now let's get to my pieces
okay I first of all what he is doing
cheating on your wife who just had a
baby despicable Despicable
there's no other way to say it it's just
evil now Ariana does I mean listen it's
not the nicest thing in the world to
cheat with a guy who just has a newborn
with a family with a wife too that's
that's so bad that's also bad it gets
worse but also I'm assuming she was
cheating on her husband because you
don't you're not together two days after
right that's why I mean you said that
those kids so soon not as bad The
Insider says some things about the
timeline we'll talk about it okay thesis
time
I do not care
personally about Ethan Slater we weren't
talking about him before this all
happened we don't really care to talk
about him right now we don't need to
believe that Ethan is a good person
because we can just be like oh you suck
okay idea of you in my brain you suck
moving on however
Ariana Grande
next we admire Ariana and we have
admired her and we want so badly to
continue to admire her
I can separate the art from the R's but
I don't want to so that's why I'm not
changing my mind until we have absolute
definite answers fair enough she
deserves that at least agreed foreign
it's announced all the news outlets are
like Ariana Grande is dating him Ethan I
think he looks better with his hair like
that yeah I agree that's an upgrade for
him
yeah
um however
this guy should inspire all the average
looking men of the world can I just say
that
sure all the average looking men of the
world rise the up
Chucky's about to get married I correct
me if I'm wrong if anybody else recalls
this I seem to remember specifically you
saying something about Ariana Grande at
one point that she would never date an
average looking guy I said that yeah
does anybody else remember that her and
Pete Davidson Maybe
I do kind of remember saying something
and you were like really insistent on it
so in a way owned Ethan oh I guess
that's true could you pulled up you made
me pull up Ricky her her the only
ex-boyfriend who's a backup I don't
remember the context I think we were
talking about I just have this like
memory of this conversation it was
during the body shaming controversy
thing that she was in okay also let me
say this to the alpha males whose whole
life mission is that
uh high-value men
get high value women and here's Ariana
Grande probably one of the highest value
in their world I mean that that phrase
is insane to say unironically and she's
picked for herself an average looking
man
uh and uh and uh and yes it does look
like Seth Green I agree with that but
I'm not not to bring him into this
um
she's she picked herself an average
looking man who's less successful than
her
and that and I think that that talks to
the greatness of women too
who are willing
to see The beauty within thank you Ela
I mean I I feel like you're joking but I
but a joke actually I like joking like I
think that
I don't know yeah it looks maybe a
little not perfect but well the alpha
males have this idea that they have to
be like
super jacked Super Rich
emotionally stunted to be lovable by any
woman
and the truth is if you ask women that's
not what they care about they don't
no they don't they ask each other
they're trying to make each other
for each other
uh but uh there it is guys
uh shout out to
Chucky and his bride
she doesn't look like wife of Chucky
though so a lot of people were pointing
out yeah he looks familiar that is
that looks just like Ariana Grande's
brother what's your argument
you were fast with that one my boy he
was ready Hart leads you home
and in a sense it's very much like
Wizard of Oz she just wanted to return
home right and click those click the
heels click the heels your brother
there's no there's nobody and and where
does Wizard of Oz take place
in the real world Kansas what is Kansas
known for
let's go next
um and now things get really really
really bad for people who love Ariana
Grande
um Ethan Slater's wife
an Insider goes to the Press
not her yet an Insider close to her says
to page six that she was completely
blindsided by his relationship with
Ariana Grande and that the pair suddenly
broke up when nothing appeared wrong
with them
which is really okay sad it gets me
consider's wife was blindsided sort of
publishing the pair suddenly broke up
with nothing okay so she's like I don't
know what happened yeah he wants to
leave me I don't understand
and I have this baby now I'm just gonna
give you because pop crave and like all
of the news outlets just like they gave
us new info new info new info so I just
have screenshots so I'll take you
through everything that happened love
that next a source close to Ethan
Slater's estranged wife so we're still
The Insider close to her says
um that she's devastated this is not the
future she had in mind that's another
quote she's such a that's terrible she's
such a victim
it's so sad I'm actually so sad for her
like she genuinely no really yes really
100 likes everything was fine they just
had a baby and then whoops he was
co-starring with Ariana Grande the most
beautiful and successful woman in the
world so he's just going to go with her
you know that's like just ridiculous and
she had her own relationship with her
which we will talk about you know it's
like when when you yes when you agree
to have a child with someone
marriage whatever you can marriage is
look at marriage it's not whatever no
I'm not a problem on its own too
right sure I mean I'm just saying it's
not whatever well but okay right
listen at the end of the day marriage is
just it's like let's let's do this thing
but when you have a kid that's a real
commitment that child needs both parents
and by the way that mother needs your
pathetic ass to be there 24 7 to help
her yes except he's on set
I'm sorry to interrupt I just want to
give a quick love update he's doing okay
he's laying on the couch right now okay
water he's chilling you want chumpa
lumpas he's taking a quick nap but he's
okay
that's good so maybe he can still go to
dinner with us yeah I think sleep it off
bro yeah slip it off I think he's okay I
just didn't want people to worry about
him did you guys make sure he's drinking
water though I just gave him a bottle of
water he's fine he's all right he's
chilling I think he's needed a purge
thank you the buzz balls but he's good I
think that that man went all out for us
he really did six buzz balls that's a
lot wow I don't it had to have been so
fast too because I didn't even I saw him
drinking one if one is like a shot then
like he did six shots in a row that's
what I'm saying is like when did he even
squeeze in the other five there's like
five different types of alcohol in these
buzz balls oh that's terrible
when I showed up I was pretty sure he
was drunk already yeah but now he's
under the care of Dr Cam he's doing good
all right all right Dr Kane you know the
thing is like you have at that point an
even bigger commitment to the child than
the mother because the child having a
child is a lifelong decision this child
deserves better the child of you too
forever so if you two split you still
need to co-parent Forever and not to
mention she just did that to her body
and now you're just gonna leave her
that's the thing too like what the
that is bro and go with the most
beautiful successful girl watch I bet it
was okay I have kids too right you know
another layer to it too and correct me
if I'm wrong but like as as a as a non
uh t as a non-t person who doesn't
really follow Ariana Grande
one of the only things that I know about
Ariana Grande is like she's the girl
that uh breaks up with guys all the time
like that's like almost part of her
brand I thought that was a Taylor Swift
thing no I might be confused no it might
just be a female music like the Mac
Miller thing and then she was with Pete
Davidson left him but both were like
serious relationships okay I guess maybe
I'm wrong right that was the impression
that I had my problem
she used to be very public with her
relationships but Taylor was more of a
big deal when they would break up I
guess
um but yeah she's had like long-term
relationships Taylor Swift is the
ex-boyfriend girl right like not to be
being to the swifties but that's what
they really have branded her as that is
that is that a mean thing to say about
the swifties he's a regular person who
writes yeah and it's probably I mean
anti-woman we stand her because I'm sure
everybody else does it
um
so then whoops Ethan Slater officially
files for divorce from his wife
so they've been dating and they haven't
even divorced
what dude this guy must
oh my God all right you know what I'm
thinking
a source close to TMZ tells uh that
Ariana Grande and Ethan are just trying
to lay low and be respectful of their
exes as they pursue this new
relationship that's on the next slide oh
you want to lay low this guy is like
he is dating outside his weight class
big time I mean this girl the first girl
you your your wife was beautiful yeah I
mean this guy must eat like a
goddamn vulture
I don't know it's I the more I learned
about him
yeah it's like the last bit of meat in
the whole that he eats it like a bit of
meat in the I got your desert yeah right
picking the bones of that okay
sucking the flesh off the bone
sorry I just had I mean this is you know
I mean he's doing something right over
there
but I know that he's a terrible person
that's everybody yeah before like I was
like I mean he looks like a normal guy I
don't I didn't think it was that he's
got an interesting look which is good
sometimes that's not a problem an
interesting look sometimes you know I
think interesting Ugg uglish is kind of
could be handsome it's always great
until they're a bad
a little bit extra so wait we didn't
read this headline this one says Ariana
Grande used to hang out with Ethan and
his wife oh no when they were a couple
later we'll get to it when she spoke
directly to the Press
there's a written thing about that and
it's crazy so he divorced she filed for
divorce yes getting worse by the minute
yeah
foreign
they're just trying to lay low be
respectful Source tells TMZ that Ariana
Grande and Ethan Slater are just trying
to lay low you're not being respectful
by your actions how are you going to say
that yeah I bet you're I bet you're
planning on laying low in your newborn's
life too there eh yeah and now
his ex-wife goes to the press okay I
think rightfully so I mean
she's allowed she's allowed time to
complain after she was five minutes her
entire life it was like ruined
um
to the press and she says that Ariana is
the story really she's not a girl's girl
my family is just collateral damage
which being called not a girl's girl is
pretty cutting oh
perspective she used to hang out with
this woman invited her into her home
presumably she was pregnant at the time
or already had the baby and now This
Woman's thinking
a woman who can have any man in the
world basically right and she's thinking
I want your man yeah
why
she's not a girl's girl I know
I want her to be
she's rightfully upset because her
marriage fell apart oh so this is in the
article she is rightfully upset because
her marriage fell apart but Ariana and
Ethan didn't do anything wrong our
Insider ads telling us that Slater had
been separated from Jay for two months
before Romancing Grande page six
confirmed that Grande and Slater began
dating two months ago after the two had
already separated from their spouses
which I that's not enough this is this I
don't know if I believe that if that's
true it certainly changes the it doesn't
changes anything in there that like
happened that was the Catalyst for a
breaking up a 15-year relationship a
15-year relationship they separated for
two months and you're already moving on
yeah you're getting married are they
they're like or no they're not engaged
like I I don't really buy this but even
if it was true it doesn't change
anything in my opinion
okay well my question is were they
broken up allegedly
before or after he had met we'll get in
because I need that time because so
later you'll see that I'm not going to
say that yet this sounds like Ariana's
PR people is just trying to damage
control oh for sure I know that it was
reported Dalton went to uh London in May
as a last-ditch effort and it didn't
work
hmm what people report to salvage yes
interesting next
okay here we go
this is from Daily Mail they talked
Lily hung out with Ethan and Ariana so
many times The Insider claimed Ariana
met their baby and even held him they
had dinners together in London and
Ariana told Lily that she wanted to have
a baby one day and that she could not
wait to start a family stop shortcut
that's crazy right
are you sure she's not the witch from
Wicked like why was she hanging out with
them so much I feel like they were
already together well maybe because she
enjoyed his company so much I don't know
but like you're like let's hang out with
your wife and child that's a personal
thing to hold the baby yeah
to smile in her face
it's downright
evil um
horrible go on
blah blah blah blah blah blah Lily
discovered her husband had been having
an affair with Ariana after that visit
but that she and Ethan made a decision
to try and put it behind them and work
on their marriage only for her to later
discover that he had continued his
romance with the singer so she's
reporting that they had an affair so
they had an affair while she was
visiting them and hanging out
simultaneously other news outlets are
reporting that they had been broken up
for two months so
so okay okay hold on hold on According
To Source Lillian and newborn son
traveled to London with Ethan when he
began filming the project in April just
eight months before she had given birth
okay so she's doing the whole pregnancy
there pretty much The Insider claimed
Lily discovers her husband was having an
affair with Ariana after that visit yeah
so after she had hung out and went to
dinners she didn't she wasn't living
there with him she was just visiting
yeah that's what it sounds I guess went
to visit sounds like why not I I would
imagine she would go with him Dalton
didn't live with Ariana in London he
would like come and go
the entire claims Lily discovered her
husband had been having an affair with
Ariana after that visit but that she and
Ethan had made the decision to try and
put it behind them and work on their
marriage only for her to later discover
that he had continued his romance with
the singer there was a period when they
were all going to try and work on their
marriage and put the whole thing behind
them the source says she thought they
were so they all knew that there was an
affair when when Ariana was there
holding the baby
yeah that doesn't make a lot of that's a
thing
I I
logistically I just like I assume so
right
that's what this says but it doesn't
make sense but if you if you think about
the timeline it would not make sense
that there was no like romantic there
definitely was romantic why would a 15
both two marriages were broken up there
had to be like some big emotional
movement happening
but why would Lily
be cool hanging out with Ian and Ariana
well she didn't know it sounds like she
found out after that visit after she had
hung out with them and after Ariana had
had the baby and she was like Ariana was
holding my baby
husband says when she went
she was
let's see
um she was eight months after this is
eight months
Lily and newborn son travel to London
need to begin filming the project in
April just eight months after oh okay I
totally misread that
so she had the baby she was pregnant
yeah here okay so she had had the baby
okay wow the baby is there and Ariana
Grande is holding it okay okay so she
didn't know
that's psycho yeah yeah and Ariana's
looking at their baby saying why would
you go and hang out with the man's wife
yeah well that's the thing is like in my
brain I can't compute that Ariana would
hang out with them if she was actually
doing that right no regular but no she
didn't know and to hold the baby that's
like Sinister Behavior yeah she did that
you think she did that oh definitely I'm
trying to put myself in that there's too
much here to be wrong there's no way
it's so bad that I like I can't I can't
believe
I just don't get it if I'm putting
myself I mean they're together now so
like the proof is in the pudding okay
yes actually they have been photographed
together but they haven't been
photographed like kissing or anything I
don't know if that if if that makes a
difference to you no it doesn't I just
don't want to believe it
but I'm putting myself I'm not I am with
the victim oh yeah me too I'm always
with the victim obviously me too this
his ex-wife has no reason to make this
up it's true why her life is a
disaster right now this is the last
thing she wants so that's why I'm always
with the victim unless you approve me
otherwise 99 I'm gonna be with the
victim I mean
this happened yeah but what I'm just
trying to get into that mind this the
mind frame of Ariana to in her mind be
like
I'm having an affair with this man
and I'm going to go visit his wife a
newborn like what's going on there what
is her mental process there
what is going on maybe his wife maybe
his wife wanted to meet her that's what
I was about to suggest is it might have
been the wife's idea
she's super famous maybe she's a fan of
her music I mean my God a lot of people
are and her husband's starring in a
movie yeah her and that that actually
that that's what happened that makes
them let's get together with the most
sense it doesn't matter let's get
together she still got together yeah I
know for sure I'm just trying to
understand what brought them together
that's the only angle yeah because yeah
like why would those two initiate it
yeah it was for sure like let's get
together with your co-star let's all
talk right yeah so they were kind of
forced in a sense to into the situation
do I smell popcorn you sure do
is it that that's not good aab you got
to make some popcorn for it where's my
popcorn we give him some well came in
popcorn I just took some yeah it's for
love love loves Papa oh he loves me he
he lives on popcorn yeah I just wanted
to get some food and stuff he has
popcorn for breakfast apparently every
day I hear the pops and they're very
serious we both put a bag every morning
to quote love he calls it I'm ready for
some yummy yummy popcorn what
fine it's John right now here he just
sent this photo this is this is Love's
world right this is what I got a lot of
corn he said to me well I should drink
more often on the show when I was hand
alert him yeah no because everyone's
just bro yeah if you do that a few more
times you're probably gonna get fired
this time is totally fine we're gonna
take care of weed we love you our heart
is with you my friend if you show up
drunk again like that next time there'll
probably be a problem it's gonna be a
problem well at least we know sweets
can't handle their booze now that
settles the yeah they're genetically
predisposed
okay I'm glad we untangled that knot
moving on you guys have some popcorn for
me though I know I kind of want some
yeah
okay I got you guys all right let's go
you know we're doing we're sitting here
doing gossip the only thing we're
missing is I thought it was going to be
a bit
okay so where where are we
that did not work out
because Ariana and Ethan kept their
Affair going despite them saying that
they were going to put it behind them
The Insider says that Ethan then
blindsided his wife by filing for
divorce insisting that the decision to
officially end the marriage was made
entirely by the actor
wow and so I mean if I'm Ariana and he's
like I'm going to leave my wife and be
like no you're not yeah right
especially after like their wife
expressed like okay I'm willing to put
this behind us let's work on our
relationship already seen already a
saint for that yes but like Ariana
probably knew that because obviously
they were talking I assume so and she
still decided to continue with this
relationship
and same for him this is really bad
stuff crazy this is deep deep stuff so
then last night as I was going to bed
there were a few more updates Lily J
reportedly deferred the idea of
releasing a joint statement obviously
why would you release a joint statement
with her former husband Ethan Slater
stating that they are committed to
co-parenting their newborn son yeah so I
imagine I feel like I know she'll be
honest PR team were like you should do a
job statement with your wife right
and she said no good for her hell no
yeah
hell no
then a few minutes later it was reported
that Ethan Slater desperately wants to
co-parent his newborn son with his
soon-to-be ex-wife Lily J and she
is not obviously she's like he's dead to
me nobody cares about what you want
loser yep I mean if you were that
desperate you wanted a divorce
job cheated on her
so the next slide is just like it's
insane how many uh news articles had
been dropped so it's just a culmination
if you go to the next what a beautiful
way to bring a child into the world yeah
a real proclamation of undying love for
his child
[Music]
school bag yeah
so it's just like that's a lot what is
all this that's all the news about it
they're just like pop right pop crate
pop right that was like let's read them
we did read them oh we read all these
like all of it got it
[Music]
um
it that one was less important
psychologists say if you recognize this
photo you have been traumatized yeah
go to the next slide
dude these stands are freaking hilarious
oh those little effects that was awesome
let me do that again thank you my first
implementation and the sound too no I
think Zach didn't exactly oh okay nice
wow plastic timing Zach
he's the goat
that's awesome brother
oh man Okay Mother's Day this year oh
he posted what no this is before
all the news broke but this is May
happy first Mother's Day
to the most loving caring and wonderful
mom person in the world
and Ariana liked it liked that post
also the picture itself is weird
that was so weird
like what are you what are you trying to
say about this child his pre I mean it
looks like a depression commercial or a
baby
[Music]
why are you it's like
it's just alone
that's what you mean to your poor child
there you'll be a shadow of what you
should have been to them wow this isn't
my first rodeo
what a freakish post
yeah that's insane that's stunning
actually yeah
Happy's first Mother's Day it's the most
loving caring wonderful mom person what
are no comments like are people like
buying it oh people are like they feel
the same as us okay yeah good why would
you do that man
why would she care that you're
complimenting her publicly yeah
for the public yeah why do you care post
what are you doing in real life for the
baby
dramatic pictures of the baby's Shadow
there's something so like demeaning
about the two people who hurt you being
like I support you on this Mother's Day
right like shut the up you're the
one who ruined everything on this one
time I get to visit the baby but you do
all the hard work
that's her baby that's all Rihanna's new
baby
the baby are you gonna call me auntie
Ariana Mama
step mommy step Mommy it's a mommy
makeout day okay now
this is a Paparazzi photo of Ariana on
her birthday
um which was June 20 June 30th maybe
around then but these photos just came
out of her with him on vacay it was in
June this year private getaway at SoHo
Farmhouse and then that guy on the left
is her one of her best friends Doug
Ariana Grande celebrating her 30th
birthday with Ethan Slater at a private
getaway in SoHo Farmhouse three weeks
before their romance was reported
Ethan Slater is such a cursed name yes
and in this situation he is by far the
one making the worst choices yep by far
other people are also making bad choices
though too yeah yeah look at you Ariana
your 30th birthday and you've got it all
made you're with a married man with a
kid
what could be more what could be a
better choice talk about bad choices
could have any man in the world why
would you pursue a merry band
with a newborn child
yeah literally anybody else
method acting
I Thought I Loved Ari what you preparing
for
in their movie you said that that the
those characters that they're blocking
are in love in the movie right no he's
in love with her she is not interested
it's an unrequited love I say yes it is
she pawns him off onto someone else
where we go from here so your conclusion
was nothing changes until anything is
certain I would love to love Ari
I haven't
fully
what is uncertain for you let's start
there I can't believe anybody
would do this you know what I mean like
well so the wives I know the wife's
statements came from a source not from
her so there's no first hand
uh it was also reported that she was
going to like every news Outlet yeah
yeah but it was being reported that she
was going to news outlets
is she on social is he last
I don't know
I mean if that's true then it happened I
mean oh yeah thank you Lena I think I
need a few days to accept it it's
horrible I hate it and so how's the
fandom reacting to all this because she
has a ton of stands right yeah I think
very similar
to the way I feel I denial a little bit
like a little bit of I mean I'm except
to be honest I accept that she has done
this this is horrible this is literally
the worst thing ever I wish that she
didn't obviously
um
yeah I think everybody's feeling that
way a lot of people are in much more
denial they're like absolutely not news
outlets are like blah blah blah they all
they do is make up lies but
the morals in the the Grande stands are
that like if she did do this that sucks
so if you think about it as like
a victim and non-victim situation right
the wife is the victim yeah Ariana's the
villain what does the wife have to gain
from lying about this stuff well we
don't so so the question is if this was
a lie this there would already be
debunked the wife would say this is not
true the doubt comes from it wasn't a
first-hand statement from the wife you
always got a pointed out she was saying
that it is it's a source close to the
wife I think that's the only thread of
hope they're holding out for
right
to the wife but every quote they used
was from a source
so
I agree with you that it happened I'm
just I'm going to explain Doug so the
denial that they're going through maybe
she doesn't want to say anything
publicly who otherwise she doesn't want
them I mean her publicly they might have
an agreement in divorce
yeah
not two maybe she can't talk about it so
she has to say it through somebody else
yeah yeah
it's it happened though it happened this
sucks yeah it sucks
oh thank you SpongeBob dude I
know
No Ordinary sponge
this is like Jack's level of
backstabbing it's really bad this could
have been a good season of Vanderpump
yep
wow I I need to know people are saying
she's done it multiple times what's up
people are saying Ariana is a
homewrecker or like like she's done it
multiple times I know that
there are um
situations in the past that don't
directly mirror this but some people
have said like
we were on a break and the way I like
Cassie Davidson they were she was on a
break from Pete and um she found out
through Instagram that he was dating
Ariana
um Naya Rivera wrote in her book she
walked in uh she was engaged to Big Sean
she walked into her house and Ariana
they were collabing Ariana was sitting
on the couch but then they did go on to
later date so
there's a little pattern on Behavior too
oh yeah yeah you dude
well I guess that's all we have to say
about that yeah
[Music]
um
that was another good PowerPoint thank
you I mean it's this this is high tea I
mean the stuff that you bring to the
table the detail the stories are
unbelievable I mean it's unreal wow
thank you so much
so the next one you're working on a Doja
boyfriend one right yeah I
she's so annoying in this story though
it's like it's pretty she's just so
bitter really it feels like it yeah
there's something else happening it
feels like well she's been having a lot
of meltdowns on social media yeah ever
notice yeah something's happening
okay
hey I want to show I want to get your
take on this either and everybody I
guess
so this clip from Good Mythical Morning
emerged
and there's a contestant
and we cannot decide if she's making a
H3 podcast reference or not okay
or well a lot of people believe she is
but here let me play it Lindsay where's
your favorite hot dog spot I don't know
a pinks is not too generic I do really
like
it
110 now now here's where I investigated
this I went The Kinks does not have
different flavors of hot dogs all
different flavors nobody has different
foods nobody refers to hot dogs as
having flavor other than Jimmy Lee
that's gotta be an HP fan it was so
slick though it was great we have to
find out if she is or not I don't know a
pinks is not too generic I do really
like it they have a lot of good yeah
different flavors
flavors
some I feel like
the pinks is a dead giveaway that's a
fan right there you think so oh yeah
without a doubt if she is she's the
greatest I mean because that's the other
thing nobody else names pinks is their
favorite hot dog place
people do people like pinks
I think it is a reference you think so
yeah I want to believe trust me I do I
just don't want to get too excited
because I I love when people do this
slip in H3 references and media it's so
good it's like a Baba Booey man right
exactly because like you said why would
she mention flavors about a hot dog yeah
nobody else where's your favorite hot
dog spot
I don't know if a pinks is not too
generic I do really like it they have a
lot of good yeah different flavors
yeah I feel like you're describing a hot
dog they have different types of hot
dogs right different the variety who
flavors it's not flavors Baskin-Robbins
you know
let's do a poll I'm curious what the
people think all different flavors we
need to we need to find her and we need
to hear from her chocolate mocha you
know Collard cream yeah they're all
different flavors
well different flavors
well I love Jimmy Liam
he's such a gay person
um guys let's get the votes in the other
night I had my phone on do not disturb
and his text for some reason was the
only one that went through to disturb me
well you had the option to go through to
ignore that if it's like an emergency it
says do you still want to notify them
anyways that's probably what he did and
he said
he's just sending me his YouTube videos
too like give me a selected it's an
emergency to send me his yeah his most
recent YouTube videos yeah dude how does
he even know how to do that anyway you
could do that yeah he's coming back out
here in a few months and he's been
hounding me every day about it is that
what he asked you about cam oh all the
time I'm being I'm coming out in
September ready this is probably how he
texts
[Laughter]
hahaha
so how does he figure out how to bypass
though that's interesting no he's crafty
like that
should we do something with Jamie in
September no
are we still detoxing from the Tomato I
think we should have real Tomatoes this
time
I Can't Get Enough Jimmy Lee personally
but
can we get James weiner instead people I
love James weiner too
I like when James weiner co-hosted
yeah maybe another one yeah that's true
that was a good game's wiener he was
really good
um
okay well shout out to this girl the
fans agreed
y'all are saying
uh 77 say yes
it's just too cool
so cool
so cool she's so cool he's so cool
oh I didn't know about this
have you I don't I feel like I've never
seen that notif A B has notification
silence notify anyway you just click it
yeah uh people told me about it I've
never actually paid attention to what
that means Jimmy dude that's
wild so funny
that's wild Jim it's urgent don't do
that 9-1-1 looks like pager 9-1-1 my new
YouTube video is out
911 call me back immediately
um
let's see
let's see Jax films is beefing with
Sniper Wolf is that interesting what
like a jokey way no no no it's actually
real beef I want to see I don't know
it's like the most like random beef
possibly come up with
Jack film Jack film is a friend of the
show
sweetheart I go along since we had him
Eric
that's true it's been a long time yeah
but um from the past he's a great guy
really a sweetheart
yeah we've met him a lot of times and
he's always been so sweet he's been on
the show a ton of times
and um I see what's going on here he
started using sniperwolf's thumbnail
former
and which is very funny if you go to her
her YouTube channel is pretty incredible
what no she's achieved view wise
um
I mean her thumbnails are stunning it's
iconic at this point they haven't
changed in years too it's just like the
same two
it's fantastic you post a video every
day just reacting of
this random videos Whatever She's
Got an oil machine then if she's doing a
video every day every day and they're
pulling in like almost 2 million views
that's hard to do
um
it is hard to do
it it is
although the effort of her videos is
stunningly bad
she's one take I don't care what it was
I don't care what I said that's the
thing she's like oh wow that was crazy
I'm like that's it listen Somebody's
Watching it's got over a million over a
million views per video let me go to the
comments like who is it watching these I
would wonder
um wow so amazing I'm sure she
definitely credits everyone in her video
oh this well this is the this is Jack's
people
I see the war has become okay we need to
get
um briefed on the war but I mean like in
a back I mean hey get it girl I mean
damn she's one of the like most
successful YouTubers in the world right
now her her monthly views are insane
yeah 34 million Subs almost
like look at her monthly views I mean
she's absolutely slaying the YouTube
game
216 million views last month wow
what yeah it's like PewDiePie numbers
yeah
35th wow
right entertainment rank oh wow
wow so I mean she's crushing it and you
know I mean good for her I don't know
whatever I'm not I'm not I don't have a
dog in this fight I mean I like Jack
right but um
I'm not familiar with the content too
maybe she's doing like so flow stuff I
don't know jacket off but I'm not gonna
hate a successful woman you know what I
mean just cause
she's getting paid out there dude
so the people
[Laughter]
all right
the beef started Brewing last year
would sniperwolf purchased a seven
million dollar mansion
and Jack started a secondary Channel
Jay Jack's films to parody her Channel
and have his audience help get a mansion
too
for contact sniperwolf makes reaction
content yeah which we look there's many
people criticize it
for skirting the line between fair use
and content theft sure okay
I see that I've watched her videos okay
because it's like reacting to somebody
else but barely saying anything kind of
yeah it's not transformative at all
because it's got like a funny video got
it and she's just laughing at it got it
it's like Jinx pretty much yeah I
remember those kind of channels you know
when we started making reaction videos
that's what was different about us
because they were people doing that but
we were like doing way way different
than that you know but I remember those
channels
well they've never gone away apparently
I guess and they're still super
successful
um I mean it's kind of like um Reckless
recklessness is basically like a whole
MTV channel now right ridiculousness
ridiculousness
but they license the videos I'm sure at
least
for sure right
the the ridiculous show or whatever 100
okay yeah if it's on TV like that they
have to they have to get clearance okay
I'm pretty sure they they pay people for
that okay that's why viral hog buys
all this for the chance
comes right right
but I have to imagine her content is
getting claimed a lot and I don't think
she can say about it that's
possible uh yeah I mean they are she
doesn't do it live they're edited so
they may you know carefully select them
they might check for copyright or
whatever but you're probably right that
if I'm viral hog or one of these
I'm watching every one of her uploads
right right you know but but I mean look
she's getting 200 million views so she's
still getting banged no matter either
way you cut it yep yeah but I have to
imagine a lot of claims okay
so
okay so here's where the beef began
let's see so I think Jack is making a
very fair
rip at her
I mean
look girl you're on top of the world
you're making a ton of money you've got
one of the most successful YouTube
channels and let's let's be honest your
content is low hanging you've got to at
least own that um
so here's yeah
um nothing wrong with being self-aware
you know yeah so here's the thumbnails
on his
channel on his new channel
you know
the views are not bad I mean he should
have stuck with it
so things came to a head last month when
YouTube tweeted out where does
sniperwolf get video ideas from from
fans now that I find a little bit stupid
that YouTube would co-sign where did you
get these wonderful ideas from I mean
what the are you talking about yeah
Jack quote tweeted this with a sarcastic
reply and from that point on they
started arguing it all took place on
Twitter folks correction okay took place
on x
it officially uh flipped over at least
on Android devices
so you can say YouTube Twitter do you
say YouTube X out a new app yeah x dot
an X recently
x x x
of course by the way Alex such a great
guy and fan of the show is what was
watching when we were talking about him
oh he says he
oh he says that he's in touch with
Damien Eckles and he already he he or he
knows a guy that is well and come so the
same oh you know someone that knows him
I think that guy might have DM me
earlier if I was gonna drop it in chat
uh same but he also he also
oh Alex did an interview with Mark
uh boarshart the guy the main character
from American movie he did oh what
that's such a trip
um anyway
[Applause]
so X sorry sorry sorry
Indonesia by the way blocksx.com the new
domain of Twitter over online adult film
concerns
it's X-rated
what a
can't get over that guy all right so
where does sniperwolf get her videos
from uh YouTube creators tweeted out so
dumb come on my dude
oh because she's doing the YouTube
keynote uh at vid which is awesome
like what do you what's your advice
I mean she's a very successful YouTuber
it's not totally true yes
but yes
I mean does she like she's known for the
reaction content does she make other
videos she might that's what it's
actually possibly before she was doing
cosplay stuff and I think she was a
streamer yeah and I didn't even know she
was doing in this reaction meta and then
one day I stumbled upon her Channel and
I was like whoa what the because
they all had millions of views right so
so I think this is yeah see she used to
stream gaming content on her Channel but
the last stream was two years ago but
you know people have always been really
mean to her online and I've always yeah
I've always sympathized with her because
it's like just one of those generic I
don't like women yes that's my problem
gamer girl stuff yes it's hard to
criticize her
because I don't want to join that party
yeah you don't want it and I think
that's why Jack was like making it clear
that he's more upset with YouTube
endorsing this because it's especially
as the speak uh the speaker she's
encouraging people to steal rather than
create and that's what he was pissed off
about
right and I think he has a Fair Point
again that's what I said I don't think
she she should get defensive about this
because look you're successful we're
happy for you but at the same time
you're what you're doing is pretty ripe
for parody yeah
you know everybody needs a dose of
self-awareness like
just own your you know I don't know
how she's responded okay let's see let's
see here's what she had to say about uh
what I love his name already though
Jack's films
here's what she had to say about the
VidCon and by the way Jax film is not
one of those guys right he's not a go
home gamer girl guy
uh it's really important for me to
engage with my audience she said I get a
lot of content ideas from them in
comments it's important to grow and
adapt as a Creator I mean that's really
okay no comment Ryan well she adapted
all right sure I mean she found this
meta that's getting her 2 million views
a day I read the uh she definitely read
the writing on the wall yeah
so Jack said uh sunglasses thumbs up
heart emoji in response to that
with a picture of her thumbnails I guess
to in essence to say wow great content
super original content ideas
right
got it being a little snide being a
little sad yeah yeah yeah so she
responded
I'm gonna have to start charging you 20
since you get your ideas from me
laughing face now this seems this
doesn't seem like a super butt haircut
seems like she's just goofing with him
about his jjjax films Channel
and she did like a snickering I feel
like this was a
nice spirited banter banter tweet seems
to me
um 90 of what I upload are my ideas
people copy me and then people like you
get confused oh wait so now she's
serious
she posted a picture of Mr Beast and
said he's stealing her
that's that's crazy I mean you just
react to viral videos it's not what is
your idea that you're facing what's the
idea of a thumbnail yeah
that's that's nuts that is the worst
maybe the worst comparison in history I
mean it's yeah you met you you invented
soy face have you seen Mr BEAST's
thumbnails
it's true trying to step up okay okay so
my opinion is changing now after reading
this second one this is this is
so not it
you're really you're you're gonna
complain that people aren't original I
mean that's just so odd
okay so Jack responded honestly don't
know what she's talking about here
unless it is the jjjax films Channel
because if so man wait until you learn
about satire
I it's so hard to know because it this
seems so much like a joke
but then she's like no Mr Beast actually
steals my
yeah yeah that recontextualizes the
first tweet Mr Beast who by the way is
one of the most creative people on
YouTube for sure I mean right
can't deny that definitely started
his whole own new genre that nobody else
was doing yeah and all of his video
ideas are nuts yeah honestly don't so he
responded and
Jackson made a satire Channel and now
she's mad somebody says she responded
satire is supposed to be funny oh
brother oh Jesus
here we go that's like the biggest
that's always the ellest thing ever
the jokes were supposed to be funny
sat there is supposed to be funny it's a
way to undermine what I do also that's
just
that's not really a true satire isn't
always funny like it's not inherently
funny it oftentimes is
but you can satirize something to
criticize it without
it being a joke you know her her
interpretation of if it's funny or not
is so meaningless yeah I mean it's
irrelevant you know like like it's about
you of course you're not gonna find it
funny or maybe I mean I think she should
find it you could all right have a
little bit of humility it's so stupid
for so many different reasons yeah
so she says you're trying to undermine
what I do bro just want an excuse to
copy me thinking would be easy money for
him he gave up because the videos end up
getting 30 000 views guess it's harder
than it looks huh that's what I do
that's so not what he like
anybody knows him that's so not what he
was trying to do he just made a joke she
dropped the ball that always takes jokes
super far always yeah I'm sure he wasn't
planning on becoming president Jackson
yeah this wasn't like a money attempt
like a new business
um it's funny to me because she I feel
like she would have looked great fine
good sport if she would have just
stopped somewhere like here but like her
actually getting defensive about this is
really gross
Jack said this tweet came from a
YouTuber 33.6 million Subs an adult
YouTuber
she said about him the only thing is
that is funny about you is your hairline
oh no if your content was entertaining
it would reflect in your views try to
say that about me Leah
nobody would dare say that about my
hairline but yeah that's that's foul
he's right I mean what are you doing
girl why are you attacking his looks
what the f is going on here
she's lost the plot I'm afraid do you
think she got the hairline joke from you
well no she's insulting his hairline she
says he has a hairline because he's
proceeding
I know that but you're always talking
about the hairline of your enemies do
you think she got it from you does it
maybe she watches our show
you think that right I mean it's a
little bit of a stretch probably
if you do watch the show uh the uh
we could talk about this I feel like we
can talk about this and and resolve this
and turn into a nice wholesome learning
experience for everybody you can get
Jack in here too we can heal the Divide
because the truth is at the end of the
day Leah you're still getting 200
million uh views a month you still pop
in like none of you know I mean you're
still successful Queen you know I don't
know why you're you let this stuff get
to you at all take him down and you know
okay I didn't say that
Jack said I invented reacting to other
people's tick tocks anyone else is
copying me incred incredible mental
gymnastics hey YouTube VidCon are you
sure you're okay boosting her are you
absolutely sure
she responded why
I can't stand that a female YouTuber is
getting more views than me even though I
make the same content girl life is hard
so again I acknowledge that's a thing
but because she probably gets that a lot
and that's why I said originally I my
heart goes out to her because she does
get that but that's not what's Happening
Here
and I think she knows that you know I
mean like he's he
it's not like somebody said in the chat
chick she insults people's look all the
time
um especially when other women criticize
her oh so she's not a girl she's been
doing that
she's been a mean girl
just like Ariana not a girl's girl it's
not a HRA reference probably
what no I think she's just yeah being a
meanie what Nicktoons uh character is
she cheating on with
Rocco Rocco yeah
what do you think probably Patrick
Patrick yeah
um
so I don't know I feel like that's
that's not a good response it's not fair
to put that on Jack he he didn't do that
uh bro it's like the worst time to make
a comment about somebody's looks it's
like in this context that's so bad yeah
is it at all possible that she was only
aware of the parody Channel and just
thought that that was his content no
she's a Savvy woman yeah no yeah I don't
that she's that stupid yeah it's not
like Jack is even you wouldn't make it
this far
five million Subs so he's far from like
a small chance I'll say he's like a
YouTube Legend anybody that does YouTube
knows him yeah he knows I've been on
YouTube Forever he paved the way for you
yeah kill some respect yeah jack it off
girl
um she said bro stuck in 2013 and
wonders why people don't think he's
funny anymore and again you're all this
is happening just because you got
defensive yeah
you know you're doing too much now
you have everything you have the success
you have the looks right
you know what I mean
the only thing left for you
is to pay what you owe
I know whose hand you shook Leia
the views where is this going the looks
she doesn't ever show her right hand do
you know why that is
it is dirt black stained by the sins
that she's committed
she shook hands with the Devil Himself
it listens to Metallica
probably and when she sees Jack that's
some real evil like Metallica when
she sees Jack
the Grim Reaper flashes over his face
you hear that Leia
I don't know
um
she says bro stuck in 2013 wonder why
people think he's funny anymore also I
hate bringing gender into this but no
one ever attacks the male react channels
that is just I'm sorry but that's not
true like the whole big first one 14
pages 14 pages it was all about uh
Hassan our whole YouTube In the
Beginning was about male and creators
um right there were some bad reaction
videos we would talk about Jack himself
kinds of stuff well fake pranks well the
first person that was like heavily taken
down who's doing this type of reaction
was Jinx which Jack did make a video
about yeah Jinx got absolutely ripped so
again everybody talks about it that
statement doesn't really ring true to me
the and there was the whole Fine
Brothers thing too right though they got
threaded yeah I mean in fact I can't
even I I personally can't think of
another example of a
female a woman uh React channel although
I don't know I don't I'm not familiar
with the landscape but I can think of a
bunch where the dudes got taken down and
she's the only one I can think of that
was a woman who got taken down
the Fine Bros they rebranded right
what are they doing now I don't know
they became Christians man
they were newborns they had to get out
of the face I I think they they go by
like react now or something I believe
yeah they still yeah they still have the
at react uh handle on YouTube those are
two separate channels they owned Zach
they have like three main react channels
oh okay yeah uh react media I believe
that's their company
unless they've sold it which is possible
because that was a long time ago now
uh she continues for contacts Jack's
film made another Channel where he
copied my content for a few months
thinking it would blow up and get
millions of views it didn't now he's mad
I don't know that's really not what
happened
so I mean I'm definitely
with peace and love and you know giving
her all the benefit of the doubt
uh Team jacks on this one
unfortunately for her I mean he's family
so
you know it's not even bias I I feel bad
for her it's like you don't have to do
all that
you could just be the woman you could be
rich you could have it all you don't
need to be so defensive for no no reason
right
I mean at the end of the day
at the end of the day
at the end of the full day of your life
Leah I've come for what you owe me
[Music]
surrender Leah Let It Go was your Satan
voice
it's a demonic voice this is General
demon necessarily Lucifer himself as you
walk alone in your massive mansion
you feel the Flames lick up at your toes
Leia
[Music]
it's time
it's time to pay for what you owe
the Mitch is getting me every time
and when that and when the soul is
sucked from your feet down into the
Underworld the money won't matter
you can't take money into the Afterlife
so true the videos won't matter
there's no YouTube In Hell or maybe
there is it depends
nothing about YouTube in hell yeah it's
just just blippy
no just blippi making a diarrhea oh my
God over and over again for eternity oh
we got a visitor
[Applause]
with the bag of popcorn with a smile on
his face
how are you feeling buddy what was that
how you feeling I'm feeling uh drunk
grunked grunk so I I started drinking
like 20 minutes before the show I was
like I gotta go to juice up real
quick
don't do that so yeah you're no longer
uh maintaining that you're sober I
haven't drunken anything
I did drink
oh my God
these things I had something to do six
of them yes we heard you had six of them
in that 20 minute span because I only
saw you drink one so when you started
saying you were having six at first I
wasn't sure if you were okay I had six
minutes uh or six of them uh
uh before the or five probably for
before the show and then I went to the
fridge and got another one okay lesson
learned right those sneak up on it
there's like four different types of
booze in there
I've been where you're at and I just
gotta say that I stand with you my dude
you know I I don't we've all been there
yeah right I don't usually drink that
much because
um like when I'm out and stuff like that
I feel safe drinking and getting blasted
but you know amongst friends amongst
very nice colleagues I did feel safe to
get a bit juice
you know everyone in here has been
coming checking me with me cat made me
some popcorn I think it was scary I
honestly don't really know but I think
it was cam it came with some popcorn and
that really helped uh so yeah shout out
shout out shout out listen shut up if
you die on the job I would look really
really bad right maybe you remember this
yeah of course busted that out for today
huh
that used to be um oh did you find that
yeah I used to wear it a lot this outfit
went from Super Couture
waitress
it's kind of awesome though
like you work at Disney or something
yeah I love that we were cleaning out
the closet this week with all the old H3
props and stuff and I found this and I
was like I gotta put this on Friday if I
might say Eva's next Vlog is gonna
consist of a lot of H3 lore yeah oh
that's fun right thank you Elena that is
true you guys cataloged the uh cleaning
out oh that'll be great
yeah
exciting
so anyway about Jack's films first of
all just just to speak on Jack's behalf
the last four four weeks his videos have
been doing really well okay 730 850 500
000 1.1 million I mean bro why you why
are you talking I wonder if your
views are the same do you think they
would both come on the show together it
depends on Leah I think Jack would Jack
because I think Jack is like he's
I don't think he's not a hateful person
no he absolutely is not if Leia would be
willing I'm sure that we could part we
could end this thing amicably you know
what I mean yeah maybe even get a collab
going
that to happen I need to double react
because I feel like she is I think she
must be defensive because she gets a lot
of hate from men true that's the sense
but he's not that guy yeah I think maybe
we can get
some resolution here right I think
that's a really great idea
let's see Leia if you're watching
open invite open invite so but he has
been uh it seems like he's been doing
this he's done two videos about her on
his channel here's one from four weeks
let's see
it's called sniperwolf but every 10
seconds I read a tweet she sent me
tonight
and today we're gonna try not to get
uncomfortable it's gonna be very hard
and I gotta be I mean I love that all
the tabs open and
how messy and crazy it looks
picking up quarters
you could see her quality of her the
only thing that is funny about you is
your hairline if your content was
entertaining it would reflect in your
views
oh another one is in my lucky day you
see her yeah I think you're getting a
little too excited like oh it's a little
bit for kids somebody oh yeah I think it
probably is mostly kids that watch it I
see that makes a lot of sense now I have
to Humble you 20. so she's she's Bob
sagitting it
kind what does that mean he was
America's Funniest Home Videos
got it got it he was the first YouTuber
in a lot of ways wasn't it um
yeah and wonders why people don't think
he's a friend of the show man right
right yeah come on anymore
this is what Jack does he he does a bit
and he really commits to it yeah yeah
thinking it was gonna be a quarter
that's on you honestly the best thing
about having one of these sink traps I'm
a Zombie right there the best thing
about having one you just take the okay
oh so she literally describes what's the
best thing about having it I I must
admit
the last time that we visited her
content was a couple years ago and I
remember it being
even
less input like the video is actually
pausing and she's like stopping and
talking for a little bit
I I seem to remember that she didn't
used to do that so you're right I think
I think it would just be more like
literally the videos would just play
continuously and she'd be like oh wow oh
that was crazy but now at least there's
some commentary going on okay it's not I
don't know if you could even call it I'm
just being honest commentary she's not
it's not really talking about the video
she goes no no the best thing about the
sync train is that you can take it out
and dump it in the trash and put it back
you know
it's not like a fair use commentary
she's not talking she's not talking
about the video itself
talking about sink drains
sounds like our show a lot of the time
well we're not talking about the videos
I'm kidding when we go off on a tangent
nobody's coming to watch whatever we
watch yeah sit through three hours we
talked for like an hour and 15 minutes
at the beginning of the show it's
literally the worst place nothing yeah
yeah yeah
we need to know need answers
please
[Music]
but I mean look at the end of the day
she's enterprising she figured out a way
to make a load of money and be
successful that's just like you know
yeah it that's the bottom line
it's like yeah I'm jealous of that too
she's got the best job in the world she
makes a ton of money yeah I'm jealous
I thought they're wrong with that
not really Joe I understand the feeling
she's an easy target and she gets a lot
of hate from men we can also all agree
on that
so I have a soft heart to her my heart
is open to her yeah
anyway here's Jack's new
new video about her uh let's take a look
let's do this one last time
this is Sniper Wolf oh this is a
straight takedown video
she's a YouTuber with over 30 million
subscribers oh my God he uploads daily
and her videos get at least a million
views each
oh what does she do
she steals tick tocks and reacts to them
oh Jack is he's he's out this is it it's
work time he heard the war ones yeah and
at the same time I 100 listen if I was
on him you know I'd be going
ballistic right if I was in his oh we've
seen it if I was in his shoes they'd be
like I'd be getting sued probably
already
here and I mean this it's still it looks
like a cartoon
let's talk about how to reaches this
free booting is in each of her hundreds
and hundreds of videos she plays other
people's tick tocks and provides
extremely base level commentary
[Music]
wow if you want to support the original
creator
uh too bad because the only links you'll
find in the description are all sniper
wolves
that's shitty
and that's a very deliberate choice to
do that yeah you know
okay and my favorite part is that half
of the tick tock she included is it
possible she licensed her videos no no
it's not possible because she does it
every day you couldn't possibly do that
right
that's interesting because that's a big
team she's so big at this point she
could have a team that would be really
really really interesting yeah
but it seems unlikely to me but I guess
it's possible it is possible because
yeah like you said she's has quite a
machine and uh content machine going on
here
and like you said if it if she's not she
would get claimed every single time
probably yes very frequently absolutely
it's either crop out the original
username or just straight up don't have
one to use a recent example from just
three days ago she features 19 videos 13
of which don't have any identifiable
usernames that means there's no way to
find and support the original creators
here all of the views and all the
revenue goes straight to sniperwolf you
know the phrase work smarter not harder
well sniperwolf does neither she just
steals she doesn't credit anyone and has
become a zillionaire in doing so
a fire Hydra exploded and the water's
just going everywhere pretty cool now
some of you I mean I mean it's like
talking to a baby that's what I mean
yeah she just describes what's happening
because she doesn't know what else to
say because it's just a funny video
there's no commentary to me yeah he fell
down
yeah
you might be thinking so what who cares
she's giving creators exposure
permit saying Jack contacted people and
they said she did not
so he answered the question there you go
I guess we should watch the whole video
then damn I mean he went through
the effort to do this to defend himself
I'll I'm gonna support my boy here
Mission from the creators to feature
their work
you already know the answer to that we
reached out there you go just as we were
talking about it what did he say
oh
so he's showing on the screen as we fix
the feed he says creators who have had
their work featured in sniper's Wolf's
videos and he has a whole list of people
that he reached out to to say hey did
she license because I mean that's that's
a great question yep one two three four
five six seven eight people as you guys
can see here let's see what he says add
their work featured in sniperwolf's
videos and when we asked them if
sniperwolf and or her team had contacted
them about featuring their work every
Creator said no wow they were not
contacted most of them were blindsided
by the fact that sniperwolf have been
using their content and some of them
were pretty upset about it okay so she
doesn't ask permission but maybe
creators get exposure from her videos
especially if you can see their
usernames right
right now if if their name was in the
the description they still would not get
any exposure still don't get enough to
like warrant no anything the only way
someone if you're in a video gets
exposure like meaningful it needs to be
like here's this user's name this is
where you need to go look at all this
cool stuff they did yes and also they
big content of hers that I've seen today
for kids kids are not gonna go and look
what's this original content you know
they're just consuming her video in like
a loop probably
I don't know I think that and for her to
be fair I think she does owe some of
these people money
but like listen they it's on it's on
them to sue her
or claim the video or YouTube or Clinton
right yeah I mean that is the resolution
right I think that is what it is
claiming the video is great you get all
the money for the whole video
yeah which is exactly and then the other
people will sue you right exactly
it's a it's a Flawless system
well let's test that theory at the very
beginning of a recent video sniperwolf
reacts to a viral Tick Tock complete
with her very insightful commentary uh
absolutely not you can see the original
uploader's username maybe they got a
little bump right
well when I looked up their account on
Tick Tock I found they had a decent
number of followers but that's probably
due to their whale shark video going
viral last year because if you look at
their most recent tick tocks they're
hardly getting any views at all which
means that no people aren't flocking to
the original creators even when their
username is displayed on screen yeah and
remember this is the first Tick Tock in
a video with well over a million views
guess who's reaping all the benefits
she's not the only one that does this I
mean people on TV do do this like Jimmy
Kimmel used to do this where he
would play viral videos and and then the
people whose videos he was using like no
they didn't even contact us
so like you know it's wrong on Kimmel
yeah on Kimmel dude he was taking viral
Clips without asking permission
because again it surprised me like ABC
that seems pretty
wild that they wouldn't uh no credit
either when did we see that I can't
remember I remember I was talking about
it but I don't remember that was a
couple years ago
believe it or not it actually gets worse
because sometimes sniperwolf steals from
other content thieves here she is
reacting to an Among Us cartoon made by
viral for you and that's not the
original Creator because we found the
original Creator it only has 1600 views
here
on Tick Tock when someone else
freebooted it and yeah that is that
sucks
here's the original Creator confirming
that their work was indeed stolen so for
everyone claiming well at least
sniperwolf's not hurting anyone she very
much is
by the way this used to happen to me
because when we first started YouTube I
was making video edits my face wasn't in
the videos and the first one I made was
was like our first firewall hit it was
all over the Internet the that's a 10.
yeah
and and it would show up all over
Facebook people would would uh
remove the watermark and pre-post it it
was getting like you know tons millions
and millions of views at the time when I
was really trying hard to grow the
channel and that's the thing with videos
like that people don't go and look
afterwards who's the creator or who made
it you just kind of like watch it and
move on that's one of the reasons why we
pivoted because I was like people don't
they're not gonna come watch from this
these videos just don't get people
interested in learning about what we're
doing 10.
cam you you've that's happened to you
too yeah that's happened to me with like
Photoshop meme should have done in the
past yeah but I guess it's not like I
don't know I guess I entered it to make
it my own but I mean in random spots
why this attitude towards her but not
has in Oh Oh you mean Hassan
I don't that sounds not doing this it's
not doing this I don't know what the
question is I mean if you go to his
channel on I've watched a lot of the
videos on Hassan's Channel
they're all like heavily commentated I
don't know why yeah I don't know I have
no idea what the question is
there's no comparison if the content is
they're heavily commentated on about the
content of the video
Yeah someone said Son talks very he lit
that legit doesn't shut up yeah exactly
yeah exactly it
inherently he uh makes it inaccessible
to anybody who's not there to watch him
but even if she did credit the creators
and ask their permission to feature them
it still wouldn't make her content any
better because man I cannot stress how
nothing her commentary is
oh what's that a whole entire car just
rolled into the neighbor's yard see the
reason I keep that's what she just
describes what happens kind of
interesting
she obviously made a pact with the devil
there's no reason anybody should be
watching that otherwise
you know and I think the reason people
watch it is because they like the
curation of the content I don't think
it's for her commentary they like viral
videos and memes and stuff and she
curates it for them and so they go there
which is
100 not fair use prop good for uh blind
viewers
she's explaining right it's accessible
maybe she's big blind audience maybe
she's being blind conscious we love that
we stand awoke Queen
keep playing these clips is because of a
little thing called fair use the
extremely important legal doctrine that
allows creators to upload content that
isn't theirs and in order for content to
fall under fair use it must be
transformative and add new meaning to
the material that's how I was able to
monetize my old infomercial and apple
parodies yeah I was using copyrighted
content but my satirical slant added
transformative value right going back to
sniperwolf her commentary isn't so much
transformative as it is just summarizing
what we're watching
it's not even content and it's so full
it's like this is what I mean it's like
one shot yeah you know
non-tent sniperwolf is non-10 hey
damn that's crazy of reactors so why am
I going after sniperwolf in particular
after all she's hardly the only person
stealing other people's content and
reaping all the benefits she called you
bald yeah that's all it takes for me and
frankly that's a good enough reason my
friend yeah for sure is it because as
she suggested that I'm sexist and only
go after female reactors well no no no
no no no and no I might want to delete
that you don't even need to
defend yourself against that dumb
but you know do you love deleting tweets
about me but more on that later oh she
erased this one also I hate oh no no the
real reason is actually this have you
ever yeah that broke your brain because
this broke mine this is the official
YouTube creators account on Twitter with
over 6 million followers acknowledging
sniperwolf as a keynote speaker at last
VidCon claiming she gets her ideas
from her fans
now there are several things wrong I I I
personally find it stunning like even
like I'm like okay do your thing
sniperwolf but for YouTube to be like
she's the beacon of creativity we want
to hold up is a little goofy they're
just so good at always backing up the
wrong people right whenever they get a
chance they do that and they won't talk
to me it's beautiful we gotta be one
that's beautiful we have to be if not
the one number one the top for sure five
or ten live streaming
users on this whole Network They
Don't Care About Us at all
but Jake Paul Logan Paul you
know let's let's put them front and
center David dubrick
sniperwolf apparently
me well it was why is it because I
said you should bleep Ben Shapiro is
that why
[Laughter]
because like that's actually a good
reason and I understand why they didn't
want to associate with me
so upon upon further investigation
[Laughter]
why is she a keynote speaker at VidCon
why is YouTube creators bolstering this
but the worst thing about the Tweet is
this getting video ideas from her fans
what ideas quite literally all she does
is upload other people's tick tocks how
is that an idea what am I not getting
here do her fans comment here's an idea
you should react to more tick tocks damn
that's crazy sorry I feel a little
orgasm here seeing YouTube and Vidcon
boost this kind of activity is so
disheartening I agree
and that is don't create steel why make
content when you can curate it what's
the point in writing music or animating
or perfecting your craft when you can
just upload someone else's hard work and
say this is nuts like I cannot even
believe what I'm seeing right now that
is crazy and and YouTube even has less
of Defense to them sympathize yeah I
mean look that he makes such a good
point here because it's like look at
this carving yeah a heart
out of the tip of a pencil and she's
gonna make way more money and get way
more views than they will and YouTube
has no excuse because this has been a
problem since the beginning of YouTube
that I know they've been aware of decade
a decade plus and
um they're still you know promoting it I
agree with Jack it's like it's one thing
to let her exist on the on the platform
it's a completely I don't think to like
put her as a speaker
Keynotes keynote speaker face yeah
that's just like you guys don't have a
brain I don't know no I agree this is
hard work and say this is nuts like I
cannot even believe what I'm seeing
right now laughs
me neither
other reasons of going after Sniper Wolf
is she made fun of my hairline there it
is yeah that's something only valid well
done valid yeah that's a green flag
right there a green light
wife friends family and viewers get to
do not useless never you
you know maybe you should react to
better comebacks because this is
embarrassing I get why you deleted it I
would delete it too
now part of the reason sniperwolf has
gotten away with this theft for so long
is that her audience is children and
exactly does he not need I don't think
he needs that pop filter Dan because I'm
using the same mic without a pop filter
it's a preference well well if I'm doing
this podcast without a pop filter then
it's certainly not needed right it's not
needed in your case because you never
speak directly into your mind so it
actually doesn't make a difference I'm
asking you a series
you're right he doesn't need it he
doesn't need the pop filter how are my
peas hitting your peas are Honestly
though like your p's are not very
prominent that's not true I used to if I
didn't use a pop filter back in the day
it was crazy Jack if you're watching
this get off look at the pockets and I
mean look how big and bulky is covering
your beautiful face your chisel jaw
maybe he likes that though some people
like to hide their face you know why
would you hide a face like that
I don't mean that kind of money maker I
mean her viewers are literally kids and
kids don't care about things like
content theft or freebooting they just
want to go to the page with all the
funny tick tocks wow this YouTuber has
all the coolest tick tocks I really want
to know how Sniper Wolf finds all those
videos to react to oh my God that's real
people that make they really tweeted
that wow it's like this is brain dead
that's I mean that's stunning I mean
it's just like
um that's the skill they're celebrating
finding tick tocks
um
real tweet from YouTube that's why I'm
starting to see why my blood's boiling
so sniperwolf's viewers don't care or
know about the stolen content
maybe we should tell them maybe we write
things in our comment section like
credit the creators or hey I wonder
where these tick tocks came from that
explains the comments a hundred percent
of them or you think she has permission
to use these or why is her commentary
not transformative she's merely
summarizing what we're watching okay
maybe that last one's a little too
verbose for the kitties but I get my
point now sniperwolf if you're watching
this
hi big fan you're probably thinking a
few things right now one is why is he so
obsessed with me
to which I say are you serious I just I
just told you that a moment ago another
thing you might actually be thinking is
he's just jealous of My Success
and you know what Sniper Wolf
I am of course I am you've stolen your
way to the top you've made your Millions
but off the backs of hundreds of other
creators who didn't really consent to
this partnership you forced about that's
a lot of videos and I'm not just jealous
I'm jaded this is my 17th year on
YouTube When I See This platform evolve
countless times since I started in 2006.
back then the content YouTube would
boost was sketch comedy Or Meticulous
music videos or content just genuine
actual content today the very definition
of content is arguable because anything
can be content
For Better or For Worse when you turn on
the water it's gonna fill up the water
bottle oh
it pours out
I'm just gonna say
this sucks absolutely sucks both the
thing itself and YouTube's promotion of
it
so now what where do we go from here
I've set my piece but will anything
actually change nope probably not
definitely absolutely not we've already
been through this yep uh on YouTube
people has been I've been doing it from
the beginning four years this is like
the Matrix you know it's like there's a
new there's the chosen one who's come to
take to break down the machine nope
Cycles baby
he's the chosen one
but it's all a game my friend
you hear the Bell Jack
wake up Jack
open your eyes Jack
it's time to begin the cycle again
listen to me
look at me
which is why I'm not done last year I
made a new channel called jija Jax films
it was a parody of sniperwolf's Channel
where I reacted to her videos but in the
most drawn-out way possible
spoke for seven days oh my gosh a whole
week to make paper no thanks I'll just
buy it at the store uh no actually of
course so it's about his commentary is
actually probably more transformative
than her it has a joke in it yeah
yeah he's doing it all wrong
process a whole week uh it's been one
week since you made me paper these
videos were intentionally hard and
painful to watch
which got me thinking
what if I made them entertaining
instead of playing a character what if I
just graded each one of her reactions
with legitimate criticism and what if I
credited the creators whenever possible
both in the video that's kind of a funny
idea yeah and actually it's fair use
where she's not doing it but he is
that's that's that's powerful and in the
description and what if occasionally I
Enlisted the help of my good friend Jack
GPT Jarvis please write a haiku on why
freebooting is bad
pirates of the web snatching memes with
no cred
original sad
God
I'd argue it even falls under fair use
wouldn't you agree sniperwolf yeah I'm
not really asking it's minus 57 degrees
minus 57 degrees that's what he that's
what he said yeah
you try to pour a can of Coke stop stop
repeating she's just repeating what they
say louder the first video is already up
on Judge of Jack's films go check it out
and subscribe because I will be
uploading there daily for as long as I
want to
all of the little guys
bottom line effortless reaction content
has only grown more common since the
days of jinx and just because it's more
normalized now
doesn't make it right I will continue to
call out thieving mooches like this and
I hope my fellow creators will do the
same now if you'll excuse me I need to
find a good home for this small glass of
wine shout out to the people that
actually make stuff mwah so
um that was a great video Jack yeah I
thought that was that was that was
really well done and here well made and
I feel like you answered all the
questions that we had right oh he's he's
killing it look two days ago 300 000 one
day ago 250 four hours uh 80 000 this is
powerful stuff here let's get a little
taste of it
delivery driver's eyes so he chased him
whoa whoa Gamers I'm sorry this doesn't
happen all the time credit to the
creators oh my God we have uh a tick
tock submitted by the No Cap Capper
possibly although I also well um we also
see a a weird yeah
a mystery watermark
laughs
[Music]
I don't understand package thieves like
y'all know what's inside that you know
it's so interesting I you don't
understand package thieves I guess we're
like because I don't understand uh
content thieves I just don't you know
like ask permission if you're gonna
feature and credit the crew so here you
go uh jjjax films all right
well done to Jack's out there fighting a
good fight I guess still
even though he's balding
how dare you he's still out there
um no I said more impressive but that
was fun that was fun
um shout out Jack's film
well I guess we've been going for a long
time how long we've been
going uh three hours and 40 minutes yo
that's a Friday episode right there okay
well I showed this before we leave so
what oh you pulled up
um that I will be posting a new video
soon and I just wanted to show that I
finally changed the channel name Rebrand
pictures
[Music]
[Applause]
official nice who wants to get on the uh
the excavator
step right up me let's go
[Laughter]
um
all right guys listen it's been a great
episode it's been a journey yes there's
been lots of UPS
not that many Downs yeah it's been a
it's been a good one down dead love went
down pretty hard actually
but we got an Olivia original PowerPoint
that was awesome yes
I mean I love this story too oh yeah and
Happy Birthday
[Music]
oh and X platform looks like he donated
are they the platform donated 100 subs
thank you so much send it to my ex no
way come on he's trying to bridge the
gap thank you ax Ethan you're in a
buzzfeed article about Alexa Nicholas oh
that some articles are writing yeah
about it which is good I'm happy for her
that that people are listening to her
that's fantastic
listen it's the weekend it's Friday I
hate to say goodbye because uh listen I
love to be I'd be here with you guys all
day if I could I'd never leave in fact
I'm announcing my very own
[Music]
24-hour day streams baby nice though I
never have to leave you guys again
I never did the IVF update honestly
there's not much they said to go in
Monday for a test a blood test and then
we'll get results so so far I'm just
waiting still taking hormones twice a
day
very annoying very annoying how do you
take the hormones you really want to
know okay I got you yeah you can say
because I was like I don't remember
because before I was doing it I will
tell you guys it's a vaginal insert yeah
right twice a day how big is it it's not
very big but it's very annoying and
uncomfortable it's it's a icky feeling
throughout the day I thought it would be
like more injections
they have it also as an as a shot but
that shot is apparently very painful at
the bottom ah and so otherwise better
that always better
well I can't wait for you to be done
with it I know she's almost done I mean
we'll know in a couple days
Monday Monday apparently but uh at any
rate guys have a fantastic weekend we
love you thank you for being here to all
of our wonderful members uh all of our
viewers we love so well thank you
specifically I want to thank our members
who support the show monetarily it means
so much but a huge thank you to
everybody who comes here and watches
it's uh really meaningful and thank you
to all the donators I know we haven't
been good at reading that yeah we missed
some today but um thank you guys
nonetheless we do appreciate it very
much and uh listen stay out of trouble
you crazy kids
and uh have a great weekend listen to
the Bell Tolls for Mitch
don't make any deals with the Devils
okay guys stay away
[Music]
foreign